[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the big breakup
of Elmo and yay yi yay
watched the video yesterday
clip of Kanye West
now appearing to praise Hitler not
appearing he was he was praising Hitler
if you're wondering
um what anti-Semitism looks like
you should not wonder anymore this is
exactly what it looks like and this is
the Republican Party
and you say what do you mean what do you
mean it's Kanye West no it is the
Republican Party
he's he's gone on Tim Poole's podcast
he he went he went uh to
Infowars Alex Jones you don't get more
[ __ ] you don't get more Maga than
that
speaking of manga he showed up on
Thanksgiving to Donald Trump's
Mar-A-Lago
his apartment inside a golf resort that
is under federal investigation
who is the only the only
person that is in the Republican primary
race right now besides yate but he's not
he hasn't filed anything he's just
talking about it
this is Republican politics folks
Jim Jordan
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
tweeted from the house judiciary
a GOP account Elon Kanye Trump
or whatever ordered I don't know what
orders it doesn't matter what order it's
in
he deleted the Tweet after the the
Hitler debacle yesterday on Alex Jones
Infowars
and then Elon had to ban suspend Kanye's
account
on Twitter
because he was posting images of a
swastika inside the Star of David
and I don't care what kind of [ __ ]
excuse you got about what the swastika
originally meant and and all that
nonsense you're a bunch of dumb [ __ ] if
you're not aware
of how that symbol was appropriated and
what it means now
just try to justify that [ __ ] all you
want and try to justify what Kanye said
all you want
Alex Jones was trying to give him an out
now Alex Jones is in a lot of trouble
here he's apparently filing bankruptcy
trying to get away from the the
gazillions of dollars that he owes
rightfully so the the the family of the
victims of Sandy Hook because of his
lies and his misinformation
and his defamation
so he's in high trouble and he knew
having kanyeon would get him a [ __ ] ton
of attention which it has and it should
folks we can't look away from this stuff
this idea that we cannot pay attention
to this and you can oh stop talking
about Kanye listen
Jim Jordan
who they who they think is a serious
[ __ ] politician
Jim Jordan is not a serious [ __ ]
person let alone a serious [ __ ]
politician they want him to be the head
of committees [ __ ] is tweeting
from an official committee GOP house
judiciary
Twitter account Elon Trump Kanye they
only only until Kanye West decides that
he loves Hitler I'm not [ __ ] he says
this he loves Hitler
only then is that the line
that Jim Jordan has to not Praise Him
from a tweet from three months ago
this is the GOP this is who they are and
there's talk right now of some secret
candidate
in the house have you heard this they're
floating this idea
because Kevin McCarthy's not going to
get to 18. he's not going to get 218. I
I really don't believe there's many
Republicans that are going to reach the
218 Mark here there's just not that many
of them that will reach the 218 with
just Republican votes they're gonna have
to have Democrats vote for a speaker
because this one's too much of a Nazi
that one's not a Nazi enough
they they they always say Democrats in
disarray but folks Democrats voted
unanimously for Hakeem Jeffries to be
their leadership
Republicans can't even get behind their
current leader in the house
and get to 218.
good news is democracies got them on the
Run
foreign
democracy's got him on the Run and
you're paying attention the democracy is
paying attention that's the that's the
most important part about this whole
[ __ ] thing
this this intersection of WrestleMania
and real life because I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't care if it's just a [ __ ]
show for Kanye if it's just attention I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't care
it's the GOP has adopted this message
the the pundits the Nazi pundits are so
excited that Kanye West is going around
a black man selling their white
supremacy message and and they're
frankly they're [ __ ] fascism
he loves Hitler what more what more do
you [ __ ] need
mock-up what more do you need to know
that you are the [ __ ] ones who are
penned up with the [ __ ] Nazis
and when again I'll say it a thousand
times when you sit at a table and eat
dinner with a Nazi you are one
it's just how it [ __ ] is
there's no oh well there's an argument
to be made that Stephen Crowder Oh
there's an argument to be made about
what Kanye's no there is not it is not
no there is no argument
it's not based in any type of fact
that somehow there's a Jewish cabal
that's controlling Banks the media or
the world you are some dumb
[ __ ]
and Q Anon is a hell of a drug
and that's the point here
Q Anon isn't some crazy thing that
you're
you're Aunt Ethel believes from Facebook
it's white supremacy folks it's fascism
they're Nazis
they're Nazis
and I I know people are like oh he just
wants to call anyone who doesn't agree
with him a Nazi it's not about agreeing
or disagreeing that has nothing to do
with it we can agree or disagree on the
the amount of minimum wage or how many
paid sick days you should have those are
arguments we can have
those are arguments that we can have but
we will not we will not inside our
democracy have those arguments with a
bunch of [ __ ] Nazis no [ __ ] you that
is a line we are not going in that
universe we do not have to sit around
and argue policy with Nazis
we don't have to do it
we should mock them
we should politicize their [ __ ]
beliefs not opinions beliefs
there's no both sides with anti-Semitism
there's just not
it's not a [ __ ] thing
you just do not have the ability to
stand around
and act like your [ __ ] anti-Semitism
your hate
is an opinion
it's not
it's your belief there is a [ __ ]
difference
your belief is [ __ ] delusional
if you think that Jewish people somehow
have control over the world or the globe
or space lasers or the banks or the
media you are some dumb [ __ ]
can I give you a prime example right now
we are broadcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and this is one reason why
this this [ __ ] pisses me off more than
anything else we brought guests from the
Midas touch Facebook page we are proud
partners with my de touch there's three
brothers the my zealous Brothers Ben
Brett and Jordy who are Jewish
they do not control what the [ __ ] I say
I have never I have never received a
text message from any one of those three
guys saying you can't say this and you
have to say that not once and my mouth
is a [ __ ]
I see a lot of crazy [ __ ]
and they they probably they probably
don't like a lot of [ __ ] that I say on
their [ __ ] Channel
under their [ __ ] Banner
but even in this own this little world
that we live in on this show
you people really [ __ ] got it bad
when you think that there's some sort of
[ __ ] control thing that's happening
it's not dummies
you want real [ __ ] free speech it's
on the side of democracy that's real
[ __ ] speech
you want you want [ __ ] hate speech
you want hate speech if that's what you
mean by Free Speech because free hate
speech
isn't free speech it's [ __ ] hate
speech
and it's all based in your dumbass
beliefs which your hatred and your
bigotry and your racism and your
anti-Semitism that you hold within you
inside of you that belief you have it's
protected under the Constitution but as
soon as you start to act on those
beliefs they are no longer it is no
longer protected my friend
you can stand in the street corner in
public and yell all the [ __ ] crazy
anti-semitic stuff you want
but as soon as you get on private
property or you start to act out your
hate speech it is no longer protected it
is not free speech that's not how it
works
and Elon Musk proved that yesterday
as crazy as it is is that the bar is
that [ __ ] low for hate on Twitter now
it's ridiculous
but that's where we're at and the reason
why is because Kanye West was on private
property do you understand you [ __ ]
free speech idiots do you not get what
free speech is
Kanye West is posting on Elon Musk app
and Elon had the tech sext him or text
him these guys are texting each other
don't you wish don't you wish when your
account got flagged or you got put in
twitmo or someone reporter you could
just text
the owner of the app
go around the whole reporting
or the moderation team that isn't there
it's a whole nother [ __ ] story
of why
Twitter has been infiltrated by Nazis
hate speech is not free speech you
[ __ ] dummies
it's it's not
and if you if you go and look at our
Constitution and our laws it is not even
close to speech or Free Speech it's not
close
and just because Kanye West has the
ability because when he's on Alex
Jones's private property in front of
Alex Jones's private microphone where
he's broadcasting on his private website
Kanye West gets to say a lot of crazy
[ __ ] on that private property because
Alex Jones is a [ __ ] idiot
he is a [ __ ] idiot
but he's not free from the consequences
either
that's another thing you morons don't
get about Free Speech you never have
you think it is your [ __ ] entitlement
that you get to say whatever the [ __ ]
you want
without consequence it's just not true
the government is not going to come
[ __ ] handcuffed Kanye because he said
that crazy [ __ ] about Hitler yesterday
performance or no performance
into Alex Jones's microphone on his
website no government agency is going to
come handcuff him for that
but he's gonna pay consequences he
already did
they they torched the [ __ ] parlor
deal he ain't gonna buy parlor it never
was
he's lost almost every single
relationship that he had and really you
know that's that's the other side of the
coin in this Kanye story yesterday Gabe
Sanchez talked about the bipolar and
someone some people want to blame that
and he's off his meds and blah blah blah
blah yakety smackity I mean obviously
there's something not right about this
[ __ ] he's got his goddamn
reality all twisted up again Q Anon is a
hell of a [ __ ] drug
and I don't know if it's the theory of
well it's burning down anyway so I'll
burn the whole [ __ ] to the
ground I don't know if that's the theory
thank you
this self-destruction mode that Kanye
West is in if it's a performance or if
it's not I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ]
that Nuance that Nuance that you're
trying to put on this is only excuse for
the [ __ ] hate speech
that he's spewing into microphones
and it's only clear that it's the
[ __ ] that these crazies have taken
over the Republican narrative
Kanye West has lost everyone around him
now why do you think Nick Fuentes Milo
yiannopoulos show up
the vacuum is filled with hate
filled with it
and you think this is a selling message
for the Republican Party hell to the no
so I say keep going dummies it's the
same thing in Arizona
apparently they're going to sanction
Carrie Lake's lawyers
for making the fraudulent [ __ ]
arguments that they're making in court
over her losing the election
this is not going to go well for
republicans in Arizona I honestly
[ __ ] doubt that there will be a
republican governor for a long time in
that state
they are absolutely destroying any
possibility for that state to [ __ ]
trust them
the majority of people in Arizona voted
against Kerry Lake they didn't vote for
Katie Hobbs you can talk all [ __ ] day
about Katie Hobbs Katie Hobbs was a
shitty candidate I'll say it and Katie
can come on here and explain it if she
wants but she was a shitty [ __ ]
candidate that but that's who the
Democrats picked in the primary to
[ __ ] run
that's how elections work I wasn't a fan
of Katie Hobbs I wasn't a fan of her
candidacy but that doesn't matter that's
not how democracy works
you have elections the people speak even
if they make mistakes that's how it is
but the majority of people who voted for
Katie Hobbs I don't believe voted for
her because they were excited about her
it's because Carrie lake is a nut job of
[ __ ] wacko
and she's only proving at this moment
she's only proving why they voted
against her they're like why the [ __ ]
did you think we voted against you we
knew you'd do this crazy [ __ ]
you're an election denier of course
we're gonna vote against you because
you're an election denier and you're
denying us our right to our vote of
course we're going to vote against you
and now you're only doubling down and
proving why we did it
Kerry lake is absolutely 100 percent
insuring
that anyone who voted pro-democracy in
Arizona that they will keep voting that
way in the future she is guaranteeing it
she's doing the work for us folks
all we have to do is point it out
and politicize the absolute [ __ ] out of
it
oh Tony you want to politicize
everything yes yes I do absolutely 100 I
do I am not scared to say it I am not
scared to do it I don't give a [ __ ]
democracy is way more important than
your goddamn feelings I don't give a
[ __ ] how you feel about what I say and
when I say it how I say it and trying to
push the narrative
our democracy is way more important than
you feeling good about it I don't give a
[ __ ] how you feel about democracy if you
if you don't feel good about how the
narrative shapes out and how we expose
these [ __ ]
even if it's having to listen to Kanye
West talk about how he loves Hitler I
was pissed off when I watched a clip of
Don Lemon everyone's like oh Don Lemon
owned Kanye West no he didn't
he didn't show the [ __ ] clip he
wouldn't show Kanye West saying the [ __ ]
they're scared you're [ __ ] weak and
you're [ __ ] scared of the truth
stop being so goddamn [ __ ] snowflakey
show the clip show what the [ __ ] he said
let the world decide they will decide
the right thing trust me
you talk about free [ __ ] speech
sunlight is the best disinfectant I'll
give you an example in Kanye West's
Little World Milo yiannopoulos
and Bill Maher takes a lot of heat and
he got a lot of heat for this years ago
he brought Milo yiannopoulos on his show
my own office was supposed to have this
big [ __ ] book deal he he was he was
working at Breitbart he was he was a
rising star
in the Republican Party
and really in in [ __ ] fascist
politics in general
Bill Maher brought him on and Bill Maher
let him talk the entire world looked at
him and went you are a dumb [ __ ]
and it was only until Marjorie Taylor
Greene put put him on her campaign as an
unpaid staffer
where he resurfaced into a republican
politics here before he was doing
[ __ ] uh gay conversion therapy [ __ ]
and all kinds of [ __ ] bigoted [ __ ]
down in Florida
because if you want to be a bigot by God
you can go to Florida and you can be a
[ __ ] bigot they'll let you be a bigot
there
this all is Republican politics
and you're not gonna get these [ __ ]
Nazis to understand Free Speech you're
not you're just not going to get him to
do it I I understand it's a [ __ ] a
difficult debate you know and and again
I'm gonna try to give you the ammo that
you need to [ __ ] tell these people to
[ __ ] off because that's really what you
need to do just tell them the truth tell
them and tell them [ __ ] off hate speech
isn't free speech and you don't aren't
free from consequences of your speech
dummy style Works you're [ __ ] idiot
you don't know anything about what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
I I [ __ ] off that's that's what you got
to do with these [ __ ] and we
gotta mock them and we gotta point this
out we have to politicize the [ __ ] out
of this if you don't believe that the
2024 race has already started it is now
now is it is starting right now
Kevin McCarthy can't get to 218 there's
supposed to be a secret ballot guess who
it is it's [ __ ] Trump
Texas Paul [ __ ] pointed it out on
Twitter this this secret ballot that
they're wanting they want Trump folks
good [ __ ] them [ __ ] em either he gets to
be the speaker of the house and he
destroys destroys the Republican Party
within months
the Republican party will not survive
Donald Trump being the speaker of the
house won't do it as much as the
president United States is a very
important job the speaker of the house
is way more important way more [ __ ]
complex and you actually have to have a
[ __ ] brain to do that job
that's one reason why Kevin McCarthy
can't seem to muster up 218 in the
Republican party because he's a dumb
[ __ ]
the only reason why Kevin McCarthy is
even the leadership anyways is because
he'd like to smoke cigar and drink
brandy with John Boehner do you know
remember John Boehner what is [ __ ] John
Boehner got pushed out of the goddamn
Republican party but he he left this
with Paul Ryan and [ __ ] McCarthy
because they used to smoke cigars and
drink brandy together
give each other a good circle jerk
and wants to praise Banner because he's
anti-trump hey he's a [ __ ] idiot too
he left it with the residuals of the
Republican Party who do you think is at
fault here
John Boehner and Mitch McConnell own
this Republican party it is theirs
they let Trump take over this [ __ ] they
let Nick Fuentes they let Kanye West
they let Milo Annapolis control the
narrative
people like Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert Matt Getz Paul gozar Andy
Biggs all these [ __ ] bigots
they're letting the Nazis control their
party's narrative and we must point it
out
we must not shy away from it so if
you're watching CNN and they won't play
the clip turn it off go watch somewhere
where they'll [ __ ] tell you the truth
Don Lemon won't play the [ __ ] clip of
Kanye West praising Hitler you stupid
weak [ __ ] you weak
[ __ ]
I'm not gonna shy away from it here I
don't give a [ __ ]
I'll point it out I'm gonna keep
pointing it out especially as Kanye
continues his [ __ ] his fascist little
tour that he's doing with the head Nazi
Nick Fuentes
and Milo yiannopoulos
I don't know maybe they'll appear back
at Mar-A-Lago
Donald Trump's gonna Embrace this folks
he's acting like he's trying to you know
stay away from it nope
he will Embrace this you will see he
will Embrace this Texas Paul said it on
Tuesday he is correct Donald Trump will
Embrace this because the Republican
party is embracing this
and I'm not talking about the [ __ ]
politicians I'm talking about the base
the Q Anon base the cult that they have
built
around these fascist ideas
this twisting up of reality
not knowing what's [ __ ] real and
what's not
where where
even our [ __ ] ideas come from and
what our history even is
they are so [ __ ] twisted up and
Confused
but that's who that's who's gonna
control this messaging who's going to
control the narrative The Cult
the tail will Wag the Dog
and again Q Anon is a hell of a [ __ ]
drug
and they're gonna continue this nonsense
and Trump will embrace it trust me [ __ ]
he's over there [ __ ] retweeting or
reposting whatever [ __ ] it is over there
on fraud social chewing on stuff every
goddamn day losing his mind over all his
losses here by the way
he lost in the 11th circuit
no more special Master that's a [ __ ]
big loss for Trump we're gonna talk
about that today in bonehead of the week
on so many levels that is a huge loss
because now he's gonna have to appeal
the Supreme Court
and I don't think they're going to give
him they're not going to give him the
answer he wants which is going to be
even more [ __ ]
Grandpa pooping his pants
it's gonna be fun to watch folks the
chaos in the next few years I understand
that it feels like democracy
you know is damaged here we are not on
our heels anymore we threw the punch and
we need to keep throwing punches
it's not time to to take a breath now is
the time to lean in and keep fighting
for our democracy we have an election
coming up in Georgia
that election that election is super
important not just because we want the
51 but to send the message
the send the message that is way more
important than anything else that we can
do is send the message
with our vote
and having partners in democracy like
Generation Z gen Z
we have we have them on the ropes
now it's going to take a long time it's
not going to be one election two
elections it's gonna take a lot of
Cycles to get them to crawl back
underneath their rocks
but I assure you if you fight and you be
part of the pro-democracy Coalition we
will win
we will win
the president of the United States that
we have right now is fighting his own
battles he's keeping his head down he's
putting his shoes on and he's winning
those battles
even Newt Gingrich agrees that he's a
winner
and then he's being underestimated
and he is truly
so don't worry about him he'll be fine
the administration's gonna do what
they're gonna do and they're doing it
and yeah it's not going to be exactly
the way that everyone wants it but if
you're in the pro-democracy coalition
don't spend too much time paying
attention to that
you need to spend time paying attention
to the messaging against the threat to
democracy and trust me the
administration if they don't get exactly
what you want is not the threat to
democracy it is not
thank you
they are praising Hitler
they are cheering it
they are excited that they are going to
try to get an anti-semite
as the Speaker of the House
way more important
so don't keep Don't Take Your Eye Off
the Ball keep it right where it needs to
be keep it focused laser focused on
democracy and come here every single
weekday because we're gonna we're gonna
show it to you you know we we do not shy
away from it we're going to show you
exactly everything that you're supposed
to see
and we're gonna frame it up in a way
that you can go out and tell your Uncle
Earl to [ __ ] off
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting proudly from the
Midas touch Facebook page
so go follow us on YouTube don't forget
to subscribe we got bone net of the week
it's Friday bonehead of the week is
today in the second hour you can vote on
YouTube you can also vote on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod you can download every
single episode on Apple Spotify Google
make sure to go download every single
episode maybe listen to the you know the
first 30 minutes or something
get a refresher
every single weekday leave us a great
review while you're over there
subscribing and come follow us on our
Facebook page at the Tony Michaels you
can follow us on the Midas touch but
also follow us on our Facebook page and
come on over to twitch why not if you
like the chat on YouTube you might like
the chat on Twitch there's a lot of
people that participate in chat over on
Twitch and then if you're if you really
want to stay warm this winter go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.dtonymichaels.com we appreciate
all the support we get the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
sweaters
hoodies zip up hoodies t-shirts coffee
mugs go grab them
go grab at store not detonymichaels.com
you can also get a [ __ ] them sticker
over there people have been ordering the
the [ __ ] sticker a lot of people like
those great Christmas gifts great
Christmas gifts all right everyone stick
around we're gonna be back with a
shitless Roundup and then we have the
bonehead of the week in the second hour
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this message
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them Buckle [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
it's Friday Friday Friday Friday Friday
second hour of the show phone end of the
week
favorite segment it's my favorite
segment what do you thinking you guys
like bone of the week we love bonehead
of the week here on the Tony Michael's
butt guest so much so that we cut a
little a sliver of it
and post it over the Midas touch
Facebook or their YouTube channel excuse
me so make sure to go over to the Midas
touch Network and check out the little
clip that we post of bone net a week we
used to post the whole thing but we
realized
not everyone was watching the whole
thing so we just post like the a sliver
of it just so they can get a taste over
there
on the Midas Touch YouTube channel
usually it's the winner I don't know if
we'll post a winner today or we'll post
something else
but bone end of the week is is our
favorite segment
and we were late with the poll yesterday
because we were trying to figure out who
we were going to add we knew we knew
obviously that Kanye West was um going
to be on this poll we said that
yesterday but um we want to judge cannon
on there as well but we couldn't figure
out the third so
it became clear after the little um text
messaging battle and the
Elon and Kanye West trying to hash out
what free speech is have you said Jesus
Christ these two
Hellboy oh boy
do not understand it they just don't get
it they don't understand it they won't
it's it's okay you don't have to we
don't have to wait around for these
[ __ ] to figure out what Free
Speech actually is it's like trying to
wait around for them to decide if they
want to get the vaccine or not you
remember this [ __ ] they're like oh
you're forcing us to get the vaccine
like no one's holding you down and
forcing you to do anything you're making
your choices and you're pissed off about
the consequences of the choices that
you're making
make your choice live with the
consequence what the [ __ ] are you
talking about just like when you don't
want to wear a mask and they kick you
out of a [ __ ] place
which by the way there are no Mass
mandates right now there should be
um I I was talking about this um to
someone the other day
and they're talking about how so many
people are sick everyone's getting sick
in schools I'm like man these schools
really did not learn a goddamn thing
during the pandemic
and during flu season the schools should
I I don't know they should be like ah
mask mandates for the next 12 days or
some [ __ ] it works it [ __ ] works and
it's not just about the sick person not
getting other people sick it's about a
non-sick person you know getting a virus
it works we know we know it works
I mean it's not foolproof
nothing is really
even the vaccine isn't foolproof but
the point being is that you can actually
prevent people from getting sick even if
it's just the flu
or a cold or a virus or mono
or whatever coronavir whatever the hell
it may be
no if we can only get the world for dumb
people to do smart things but that's not
always how it works
it's not always how it works
speaking of schools I watched a clip
this morning I think Shannon Watts uh
posted it on Twitter
about a certain County Florida
that are really pissed off that you
can't give corporal punishment to
students anymore and they really want to
punish him as much as they can so
apparently they're going to get the
county sheriff
to start locking them up in jail or some
[ __ ] or criminally charging them or I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on man
they even had a press conference in
front of the goddamn jail I'm not
kidding you
you you talk about uh Marjorie Taylor
Green's gazpacho police
holy [ __ ]
these fascists can't even help
themselves they take over a school board
and they're like we're gonna sick we're
gonna sit the the gazpacho police on you
like immediate on the children they're
so oh my God they can't stop with with
kids they're so [ __ ] obsessed with it
it's ridiculous look kids are [ __ ]
right in general they haven't learned
everything we haven't taught them how to
be you know
full human beings yet they're not adults
they're not adults sometimes they're
going to do stupid stuff right they're
gonna act dumb they're they're kids
and they're not always going to behave
the best
sometimes in bad moods you know they
just their children they don't have the
full capacity to navigate certain
situations yet that's the whole point is
we're supposed to be teaching them
they're supposed to be learning these
things so now what they're going to be
learning in a certain County
is if you get in a scuffle you're going
to jail I don't understand why
why we can't see
this Q Anon stuff is fascism it's Nazism
they're Nazis if you believe anything on
Q and on hey fake Gabe
um you've been commenting I haven't been
watching you're sorry and I'm sure he's
got some Q Anon [ __ ] that he's posted if
he's here today where are you man
I'm just going to give you an example
like I can always rely on him
oh here's Jeremy Johnson he's another
[ __ ] Q anoner loves this and I oh see
here you go here you go here you go
there it is there it is there's the
there's the Nazi Jeremy Johnson thank
you Jeremy thank you for proving me
correct
he see he can't [ __ ] stop talking
about Jewish leaders
might own this spawn but whatever
whatever
could be you didn't listen to the first
30 minutes Jeremy you [ __ ] Nazi
they're everywhere they're [ __ ]
everywhere they are in your family they
are people you know the people you work
with
and that that is the point here
that's why I say play the Kanye clip
play it to your friends and your family
see their reaction
hmm
when your family member responds to the
Kanye clip like Jeremy and fate Gabe
would now you know
your co-workers now you know
now you know where they stand because
they could be like well
you know
I really that's gross or they can be
like well maybe he's got some points
nope
he ain't got no points nope
but that's that's kind of the truth you
want to know
it's kind of the truth you want to know
isn't it
that's why I like to pull up Jeremy and
and Faith gave you because they never
disappoint
I don't know I don't see fake game he
must be sick today
poor guy
well couldn't happen to a better person
I don't know maybe he's just listening
he's tired of me pulling up his comments
let me show you this
let's go to the [ __ ] let's round up here
so I want to round up these Tweety
tweets but I want to show you this video
from Shannon wants so let's start the
countdown let's go to the [ __ ] list
Roundup and let's watch this clip start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show we have
reached the part of the show where we
round up all the Tweety tweets and
journey Trends it's Brevard County
Sheriff Wayne Ivey is who is who held
the press conference in front of the
jail about the school think about this
for a second
a bunch of Q and honors take over to
school board
and the first thing they do is have a
press conference with the sheriff in
front of the jail because they want to
jail students remember remember when it
was about the Democrats and the groomers
remember when it was about that nope not
anymore it's about it's about them
jailing your children remember when I
said over the summer hey hey stop voting
for [ __ ] fascists they want to take
your consent away from you about your
children they're doing it
they're doing it they're the reason why
they're obsessed with children is
because they want to control them your
children
they want to control your children they
want to take your consent away that's
why they're hyper focused on it they are
so hyper focused
it's weird it's sick it's [ __ ] gross
but that's what they're doing
they wouldn't be so hyper focused if
that wasn't the case
but they are and here's the [ __ ] clip
um in front of the jail
in this County in Florida of course it's
Florida let's listen
they know nothing's going to happen to
them they know they're not going to be
given after school detention they're not
going to be suspended they're not going
to be expelled or like in the old day
they're not going to have the cheeks of
their ass torn off for not doing right
in class okay so the good old days the
good old days when you got your ass
cheeks tearing up now look I I I
actually as far as corporal punishment
goes and I believe that there is some
room for parents to decide that in their
own home now there's abuse issues and
some people don't agree with spanking
and we can have that debate but at a
school you should not be putting your
hands on children
any way shape form
any of it
but this guy wants wants to beat
children
into submission
so because he can't guess what he's
gonna do oh we we have teachers that are
handcuffed we have principals that are
handcuffed and I I will tell you and
I've said this many times before we got
to get to these kids before they get to
me here at this jail and so starting
right now it's a brand new day folks it
is a brand new day where School
discipline is going to be put back in
place in Brevard Public Schools so now
so now the police the police are going
to handle discipline at the school what
in the [ __ ] is going on
it's almost like I said this was gonna
happen that you that if you vote for a
bunch of [ __ ] fascists that are
obsessed with your children and your
consent for your children that they're
gonna take it away and here we are here
we are right in front of the [ __ ]
jail in Florida where they're going to
basically subcontract local law
enforcement to take your consent away
from you of your children
by arresting them and criminally
charging them I'm not [ __ ] to you
listen we have a school board that
stands behind this we have our teachers
union that stands behind it uh I can
tell you that our our team uh all the
way from the state attorney from school
district security to the principals to
the teachers we're all tired of this
disruptive behavior by just they know so
he's going to use the attorney general
and the state power big government
big government to take your consent away
from your children and he's going to
jail him he's going to criminally charge
him I think there's another clip where
he goes on I'm not going to play anymore
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] at this point
and there's another clip where he talks
about he's gonna he's gonna jail him and
criminally charge him and blah blah blah
yeah but here's the thing the good old
days the good old days
when we could control parents consent of
children like 1940s Germany like that
hmm yep is that is that what you want
the Hitler Youth I don't know these
people are all about Hitler now
they love it they [ __ ] love it and
they [ __ ] lie I'll you let me show
you the clip well we'll play the tiny
clip here in just a little bit
I [ __ ] love they [ __ ] love them
some Hitler here is um Texas Paul posted
this earlier I told you and he said it's
Trump um Ron villafkowski posted a uh a
video of Representative Ralph Norman who
was on uh Rio America's voice Trader TV
and he opposes McCarthy for speaker
um and and Texas Paul you know are one
of our favorites here and he he surmises
that it's Trump but listen listen see
what you think so your viewers also that
an outside member you do not have to be
a sitting member of Congress to serve
that's right it will be it will be
apparent in the coming weeks uh who that
person uh will be and it'll it will I
will tell you it'll it will be
interesting if everything plays out
so there you have it um the Texas ball
is thinking that this is going to be
Trump I I don't disagree with him
um I think they have a secret bout
they're trying to convince this guy to
be the speaker of the house they know it
will advance their Nazi agenda
um but I think what they're failing to
recognize is the reason why Trump is a
[ __ ] loser the reason why he's a
[ __ ] loser is because he sucks
and it sucks to suck really honestly I
don't know that it's such a bad thing at
this point where this guy to [ __ ] try
to be speaker can you [ __ ] imagine
can you [ __ ] imagine more of an
in-app person
to [ __ ] try to handle
the Congress the House of
Representatives and Trump oh Jesus
Christ at this point he can't even get
staff members that's why he's so [ __ ]
crazy and off the rails he ain't got no
one there to put guard rails on him
Miller that's who's there give me a
[ __ ] break
these [ __ ] idiots wouldn't know how
to [ __ ] run a goddamn Congress
they wouldn't know they would they would
they would be better at working their
way out of a wet paper sack and they
can't even manage to do that
so I don't know a lot of them [ __ ]
run Congress destroy the Republican
party because that's exactly what it
would do
think about this if they get a [ __ ]
speaker in the house that cannot that
cannot manage to run the House of
Representatives think about this
this is half of an entire branch of
government
and if that speaker can't manage to run
that [ __ ] house that that that House
of Representatives
they're gonna be Republicans that are
probably going to flip sides
just to gain the majority
to remove the speaker and install a new
one which we may have that at this
situation and really if Trump is there
it's going to be their go-to to try to
get 218 he ain't gonna get [ __ ] 218.
no [ __ ] way will he get 218 on the
floor of the house
this is only a step closer to a speaker
Liz Cheney right now I'm not I'm not a
Liz Cheney fan you guys know that I
she's Darth Vader Jr
there's very [ __ ] few things that I
would sit and agree with Liz Cheney on
but one of them one of them is this Q
Anon stuff and this Trump cult is
[ __ ] garbage and it's garbage for our
democracy there's one thing that me and
Lee's Janie I think agree on at this
point now we might have different views
I think it's fundamental to our
democracy to get rid of this nonsense I
think she's wanting power
now if you imagine
where the Democratic caucus
who voted unanimously signaling
signaling
unanimously that they were going to put
a king Jeffries in leadership right
think about this for a second this is
super [ __ ] important
that they signaled this
because I believe not just they're
signaling to the pro-democracy Coalition
us the people but I believe they're also
signaling to Republicans that hey we can
do a unanimous vote
we will do that that is the thing we
will and can do
now
if they can if the Democrats
can manage to unanimously vote now again
this is a tough vote for some
this is a tough vote for some Democrats
a Liz Cheney and Speaker of the House
because they're not gonna always they're
not gonna want that on their record but
we gotta look at the situation
now we're in here
now I don't know that it'll come to this
I have no idea I don't know what the
hell they're gonna do who knows what the
[ __ ] they're gonna do they don't have
any real leaders I mean they're they're
one real leader right now is is [ __ ]
Kanye West he's the one controlling
their [ __ ] narrative
think about that Kanye West is the
leader of the narrative and the
messaging in the Republican party right
now
and it's only because Nick Fuentes and
my little Annapolis grabbed a hold of
him because I've been saying for a long
time that Nick Fuentes is the messenger
for the GOP he has been for a long time
Jesus Christ his [ __ ] organization is
called America first
and they run around even the moderates
are like America first we need to put
America first wink
and we know what you're saying Nazis
but it's where we're at I don't know
maybe it'll happen maybe it won't
but I don't think we should be afraid of
them bringing up Trump on the uh on the
floor as Speaker of the House and here's
another reason why he's lost his [ __ ]
he's out of his [ __ ] mind I mean just
straight out of his mind and he has lost
at the loss at their loss at their loss
here and we'll see what's going to
happen uh with this uh criminal case
against the Trump organization his
business in New York looks like he's
going to get fined between a million and
a million and a half dollars I think
they've done a good job at framing this
case and then who knows what happens
with the civil case against his business
with tis James but let me tell you
something this 11th circuit
overturning Canon's uh uh special master
boy that's a bad deal for Trump that's a
horrible deal for Trump because that
that
gets rid of the stall tactic because
that's all the special Master is the
[ __ ] stall tactic
I mean it's not going to help him in the
long run evidence is evidence the
special Master is not going to give a
[ __ ]
if you if you think evidence isn't
evidence it is it or it isn't and
they're going to let the Department of
Justice have that evidence that that's
what it is
so it's just a stall tactic which you
know
if if if we can get this thing to the
Supreme Court and they knocked a special
Master down quick enough which they will
by the way
only disappointing Grandpa poopy pants
here even more
then here's what's gonna happen
not only is he gonna freak out but it
may give us a good Christmas gift
because I think this special Master part
is one of the things that the doj is
waiting on
well and they're waiting on this runoff
possibly
to indict
now
if
mayor Garland wanted to speed this
process along as soon as the opportunity
would present itself
you would guess that he would probably
want to make sure whoever's going to
indict Trump
has several weeks in advance from a
runoff and and the possibility of the
Supreme Court smacking down
the special master
which only speeds up their investigation
you would believe that maybe a really
smart prosecutor who prosecutes war
crimes and war criminals may be able to
step in very quickly
and make quick decisions my guess is
that we will find out
that these the appointment of the
special counsel and Jack Smith was not
designed to slow down anything it was
designed to speed it up
quickly
and they gave Jack Smith a months in
advance
to get him where he needs to be to give
us a Christmas gift and if things go our
way here with the this 11 circuit
decision on the special master
and once we get past this this this
runoff election I believe we may get a
special Christmas gift but let's listen
to how frayed the Cheeto dust Q Anon or
Grandpa Poopypants is he's gonna need a
lot of diapers here unconstitutionally
in my opinion and very very unfairly and
we're going to get to the bottom of it
and you know what I've said I take it
very seriously I have never seen
anything like it at all levels it's the
weaponization of the Department of
Justice and we can't let this happen in
our country
so I you can't make out anything he's
saying other than his personal grievance
right he's whining like a little [ __ ]
like he always does oh my me me oh that
poor me I'm the victim I'm the victim
I'm the victim even in his [ __ ]
speech where he announced that he's
gonna run for president he said
literally into a microphone I am a
victim now
what he's talking about here is January
6th and the January 6th defendants the
reason why Donald Trump
for all you q and honors and hate
Watchers out there the reason why Donald
Trump
is trying to convince you because he's
not convincing us the people we the
people the the people that are
protemocracy know this is all horseshit
we know he's an insurrectionist we know
that the reason why he's trying to
convince you
that he is he is one of the January 6
defendants is because he's going to be
he's going to be and the reason why he's
trying to convince you that they should
go easy on the January 6th defendants
you know the people who smeared [ __ ] on
the walls broke the windows I tried to
hang Mike Pence that [ __ ]
is because he wants you to believe that
he's he's kind of with him he's with him
now even though he wasn't now he is
because he's going to be one of them and
he wants the Department of Justice and
our country to go easy on them because
now he's one of them he wants us to go
easy on him well [ __ ] that but listen to
this nonsense because our country is
going not socialist they've skipped over
that they skipped over socialism our
country is going Communists this is what
happens
they can't help it they can't help it
but just like oh yeah
um it's not socially economy communist
the funny part about this the the
funniest [ __ ] part about this line
the Communist [ __ ] folks the number one
enemy for [ __ ] communism is fascism
right so like if you're staunch and you
[ __ ] hate communist and you're the
mortal enemy of communist you probably
need to look internally and realize that
he might be a little might be a little
fashy right he might just be it might be
a little Nazi creeping around in there
just saying it and we can't let it
happen we have to stop it so I want to
thank everybody for working so hard I
know how hard you're working to get
Justice for people that are imprisoned
right now and people that are being
tormented can't let it happen we're
going to stop it we're going to win
thank you all very much they're not
going to stop it and it's going to
happen they're going to be jailed and
they're going to lose and the reason why
is because he just said that [ __ ] in the
microphone to try to convince not us
that the the pro-democracy Coalition but
to convince like fake Gabe and Jeremy
Johnson that's what he's doing he's he's
duping them
that's why I like to bring him up in the
chat it's free game here yet I don't
know I haven't been paying attention
let's see
let's look at the the chat here let's
see uh are you there game are you there
where you at buddy I know I know you
just love this this the uh the Cheeto
dust cue in honor you love oh yeah you
are there you are see he's typing in
definitions of fascism
he's got he's got it all typed out to
copy and paste in the chat copy and
paste copy and paste I'm telling you
he's the [ __ ] Trump copy machine
and he takes his cue from that [ __ ]
[ __ ] box we just watched complain about
people doing crime
getting getting [ __ ] convicted
and paying for their crimes
and he's really he's really worried
about people paying for their crimes a
criminal a criminal like this guy oh my
God they get really worried about Christ
especially in a federal court holy [ __ ]
let me tell you something federal court
is nowhere to [ __ ] around with they
don't give a [ __ ] trust me I know this
they do not give a [ __ ] they have all
the time all the money in the world
they don't give a [ __ ] and one
prosecutor leaves they got another one
right behind that [ __ ]
they don't run out of prosecutors in the
federal system [ __ ] no Hills to the no
and they got all the time in the world
everything they got to do
where's the charge C area where's the
charges where's the charges hey fake
Gabe
Stewart Rhodes and The Oath Keepers were
just found guilty of sedition got it go
look it up you want me to post a link
you want me to post you do you need me
to post a link for you fake game they
were found guilty of sedition and your
little [ __ ] Mussolini Jesus the
orange tangerino down in Florida Grandpa
poopy pants the Cheeto dust q and honor
they basically said in the trial in the
testimony that they were doing it at the
behest of him you [ __ ] idiot sedition
they're gonna go to prison for a long
time for sedition you dumb son of a
[ __ ] those are the charges I'm not just
talking about charges I'm talking about
convictions you stupid [ __ ] oh here you
go yep Trump was implicated how you're
gonna find out
you're gonna find out what do you think
J why do you think Merrick Garland
appointed Jack Smith okay
it ain't just because of the documents
fool the reason why Jack Smith is going
to oversee the January 6 State elector
scheme and the documents is because
they're related
he stole documents to cover up that he
was trying to commit a coup you dumb
[ __ ] you are such a stupid [ __ ]
you are such a stupid [ __ ] for for weeks
you said there was no criminal trial of
trump organization
and they're doing their closing
arguments today you dumb son of a [ __ ]
you were such a stupid [ __ ]
this is how you need to treat these
people to their face by the way
this is how you have to [ __ ] you have
to make them just mock them and
absolutely give them the [ __ ] slap of
stupidity you are a dumb son of a [ __ ]
you believe anything that you want to
believe because it makes you feel good
about your [ __ ] bigotry and your
hatred and that's why you love this guy
the reason why you love this guy fake
Gabe is because he allows you to believe
your bigotry and your hatred and your
dumb buckery makes you feel good to feel
stupid
what what what is this uh uh-huh a civil
trap no dude the trial that's happening
right now in New York against Trump
organization is a criminal trial you
stupid bastard
it's a criminal trial Al weiserberg's
gonna go to prison they're going to find
the Trump organization there's probably
going to be referrals to the IRS in the
southern district of New York
about the tax fraud because it's not
only [ __ ] state laws that he probably
broke with these tax frauds he was
probably hiding income from the federal
government too and that is something
that you can't do that's fraud
he's probably he's probably eventually
going to get federal charges on tax
fraud
because the feds don't [ __ ] around
they're not going to now the Civil Trial
that you're referring to is the one that
his business is in receivership for it
literally is a receivership
there is a court appointed receiver who
is who is making sure they're not
[ __ ] around and trying to steal and
hide money dummy you are stupid [ __ ]
and and you you need to get you need to
lay off the Q and armed stuff on
Facebook man you really do it would be
in your best interest and well you know
what keep going because it you create
con great content for this show
oh [ __ ] these guys yeah oh [ __ ] okay I
got um I got one more clip I want to
show you before we go to the uh maybe
two no one two I thought I had
um
um
oh yes here it is
uh Mike Flynn remember I was talking
about Carrie Link in Arizona earlier and
how the Arizona voters said hey Carrie
Lake you're crazy we don't want you to
be Governor because you're an election
denier and you're a [ __ ] fraud and
you're a liar
well apparently and the courts are going
to sanction some of her lawyers for
fraudulently
um filing a fraudulent motion which is
not you know
all that crazy now here's here's here's
the thing
Mike Flynn is doubling down on this this
attitude and the voters of Arizona are
like that's exactly why we voted you out
that's that's exactly why we wouldn't
give you the job because you said you
were going to be crazy we believed you
now you're acting crazy only only
justifying our decision not to put you
in charge like it's it's perfect let's
listen I I met with a person uh last 24
hours and you know a good person talking
about the election and we were talking
about Arizona and you know and the
comment was made that well you know it's
it's so bad it's too bad that Kerry Lake
only lost by a few votes you only lost
by a small margin I said wait a second
Kerry Lake won by hundreds of thousands
of votes I guarantee it if they actually
look at it I mean you don't have he
guarantees it he guarantees it gave
sanjez I you know what I didn't know
that Mike Glenn was the actual official
vote counter over there and uh in
Arizona but apparently he is he is
beneficial here that hundreds of
thousands
um you know Mike Flynn Mike Flynn is
always the official yeah these days I
guess yeah I mean well you know anything
you need an official for a baseball game
you know a football game uh you need
someone to monitor a spelling bee you
need someone to account or send or send
a message to Putin apparently he's
really good at that he's really good at
you know being the go-between with Putin
let's listen here though because he says
there's hundreds of thousands of votes
without any evidence of course let's
listen some of the down ballot voting
that occurred right Terry Lake won by a
large large margin it's it's solely
because of the of the horrific uh
corruption that's it that's in one in
one particular County but it's probably
in Pima County out there as well
so it's not just in but Maricopa is like
I said the poster child so now the
question really what you're what you're
raising is when is somebody going to be
held accountable because the level of
frustration by the American people is is
that an all-time high yes it is and it's
the frustration is with them like
literally we talked about this when um I
think it was Bridget Gabriel which I
think she's trending
um for some reason that's besides the
point that the point is this is that as
soon as they lost the election in the
key States Pennsylvania Michigan Arizona
and Wisconsin because that was their
strategy in 2024 is to put Cuban honors
and election deniers in charge of those
States so they could just give it to
whoever they wanted right now when they
realize that that gen Z had really
[ __ ] that up for them when they
realized that gen Z showed up and they
engaged in democracy and used the ballot
their first reaction was we're gonna
take your rights away we don't want you
to vote and then like why do you think
we went and voted against you fools
right and it's the same thing here
literally the reason why Gary lake is
not the governor elect of Arizona is
because she's a nut job she's crazy and
Arizona voters went to the polls and
said we're not going to let crazy be our
governor and immediately immediately
delivers the justification of why they
voted that way like literally the entire
apparatus around campus it also doesn't
help that on Election Day you know uh
Carey lake is saying for the next eight
years I'm gonna be your worst nightmare
talking to the Press like oh instead of
having an actual relationship where it's
a back and forth you give me something I
give you something we work together on
stuff no instead I'm Gonna Make You real
journalists and I'm gonna be your worst
nightmare yeah okay yeah you said that
why would you ever say that because not
only did people already have an idea of
who you were but now if anyone for
whatever reason was uncertain they were
like yeah why would I ever vote for
someone that wants to control the Press
like that like that's completely insane
and it really does show their fascist
kind of you know ideologies their their
way of thinking and I think uh someone
like Mike Flynn who's tied into the
proud boys and The Oath Keepers now that
the Oath Keepers are convicted of
sedition fake Gabe they're they're
Traditions tradition
um with Mike Flynn intertwined with The
Oath Keepers and brab boys I'm sure that
the reason why they were so desperate
him Steve Bannon and Carrie Lake and
Trump and others were so desperate to
win Arizona is because Kerry lake is the
crazy of the crazy and she was likely to
do some crazy ass [ __ ] as a governor
um that would be in their favor and they
could go see look Arizona's doing this
see look the state government of Arizona
is doing that's what they want you know
what they want justification and that
they didn't know that's why they're
pissed off yeah and they'll also create
it by any means necessary right they'll
even cheat themselves or they'll commit
fraud and be like see we told you there
was fraud and it's like yeah but you
guys there's voter fraud down in
Southern Florida at The Villages huh
don't you know like yeah but that's not
it's not Democrats and it's not machines
they just they just tried to vote more
than once for the same person
morons and really in fact also and it's
what
what I always laugh at is when someone's
like oh there's voter fraud okay how do
you know there's voter fraud oh that
they were caught in those and those
ballots were not counted so you mean you
mean the process the system works you
mean like at the border when things are
seized it means it works wow good job
guys it's kind of funny it's kind of
funny how that [ __ ] works you know when
it does work right yeah the work the way
it's the way you you know it works
because somebody brought it up and said
here's an example the only difference is
when you say can you show me voter fraud
Republicans are like
I mean it's it well there there was
there was that one in Pennsylvania right
you mean the guy that killed his wife
and his uh mother-in-law and then voted
for them because he was like I need
Trump who did he vote for who did Trump
he voted for Trump that's three votes
for Trump
it's just funny when you see Republicans
like they gave you like there's a bunch
of voter front it's like oh yeah our our
Democrats committing murder
and voting in that person's name no I
don't [ __ ] think so yeah well that's
that's the greatest part they're like oh
Democrats are getting dead people to
vote you're like okay where's the
example of someone voting as a dead
person like in Pennsylvania who'd they
vote for Trump yeah okay who they vote
for and then you just seem like just
disappear all right it's the Homer
Simpson and that bush type uh type meme
oh my God yeah we got a great bone end
of the week yeah it was it was it was
not tied at all was it no I mean there
was one point where I was like maybe and
then I was like really well with the the
coupling of two people I really thought
there was a chance that something based
on how the evening was going last night
I wish you and I were going back and
forth we're like oh oh [ __ ] you just
sent this you just said this yeah
yeah I I thought I thought the love of
bear ended
poetically really honestly you know I'm
gonna go on and live and say the love
affair is still there oh do you think so
you think they haven't broke up I I I
titled Today's Show Elon and yay breakup
I know I know you did but here's the
thing I honestly think look if you look
back at the tweets from Elon he goes
look I in in October he was like look I
had a heart to heart a one-on-one with
Kanye or with yay right and here's the
thing people like oh don't dead name
yate no you never I don't [ __ ] care
because Kanye is a [ __ ] Nazi his
handle is Kanye West still so uh there
you go at Kanye West is this [ __ ]
Twitter handle so I also don't care if
you're a [ __ ] Nazi and you're an
anti-semite I'll do whatever I'm not
gonna give you the respect that you
think you deserve if you change your
name I don't [ __ ] care I'm gonna call
you the same name whether it's yay or
Kanye I don't [ __ ] care but here's
the thing
I do believe based on some back to back
you had a heart-to-heart with yay
and he's like I think he really
understands this is like October 10th
October 11th or something like that of
last month just as past this past month
we're talking not even a month ago it's
December 2nd this is Elon this is Elon
it sends out a tweet and says uh uh I
had a heart to heart with Kanye or with
yay whatever
uh had a heart to heart with with uh
with Kanye and I I think he really
understands and I think we come to an
understanding like that what he did was
wrong right yeah okay yeah oh my God
fool me once fool me twice here's the
thing you didn't even need to give the
guy a second chance so no once you say
oh yeah I'm going def con three
on these people
there's no reason to bring that person
back because you know what they stand
for and then when they continue to push
those things in other mediums
interviews other forms of written
content video whatever they might be
audio if they continue to push that
ideology why would you ever say you know
what I'm gonna give him a second chance
because I think they've really turned a
new leaf and it's like no they're the
same [ __ ] Leaf they haven't turned
they haven't turned look whether
whichever way you turn it front side
back side sideways crumpled up it's
going to be a [ __ ] nonsi sympathizer
Hitler
exactly it's a nonsense and the fact
that you let that person back into the
party which mind you is already a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show as it is on Twitter
but the fact that you let that person in
doesn't show oh you're a Christian or
you're a Jesus loving person or whatever
the [ __ ] you want to say it means that
you're a sympathizer to someone who
wants to oppress other people
specifically a Jewish Jewish group of
people Jewish community that is not okay
first off hold on
I just want to call this [ __ ] out
fake Gabe go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ]
yourself because what you're doing right
now is you're trying to Gaslight what
Kanye said Kanye said deathcon 3 against
the Jews that is what he said on Twitter
he was using a play on Defcon and said
deathcon he knew exactly what he said he
knew exactly what he meant and the fact
that you want to come in here and try to
justify his anti-Semitism is [ __ ]
gross disgusting vile and really shows
us who you really are he's tried he's
tried to say dude face and he won't do
it fake Gabe you're you can come I know
where you you're I know where you live
you live in a town
not too far for me with an O people
already said in the chat so they already
know where you live you're 42 you're a
balding dude you're pathetic somebody
said maybe you were married I don't know
I feel really bad for anyone who was if
you want to come meet me
come to La I've tried calling you I've
tried texting you you do not answer you
do not respond you're a [ __ ] coward
you come on this chat and you say [ __ ]
and I tell you I welcome you meet me in
La come down to my hometown over here
where I am right now come meet me we'll
eat over a [ __ ] we'll eat we'll eat a
meal we'll have a drink together and
then I will [ __ ] own you in real time
and we'll stream it live
I [ __ ] dare you to come to La meet me
and me over a meal you ain't gonna do
that we'll put it in a civil area and
I'll [ __ ] embarrass you in front of
everyone so here is um you found this
somewhere on the deep dark web
apparently Kanye's been putting on a
list of his top fascist here yeah and
he's got the one that he loves the most
this is what we watched the hellscape
that we watched yesterday on the info
wars uh live stream and then you have um
some other guys here but here's the
here's the list in order number one is
Adolf Hitler have you ever heard of this
guy Adolf Hitler he's something else uh
yeah I think I think not a damn good
thing about him that's good not a single
thing I I I I I think though Kanye's got
a special place in his heart based on
what he said yesterday
um number two is Elon Musk wow number
two so it sounds like this romantic
um
knocked down to number three maybe not
don't know I don't know maybe he goes
down to four or five uh Nick Fuentes is
up there he's really after his heart
Donald Trump you know they had
Thanksgiving dinner together yeah
it's funny Jim Jordan pulls down the
tweet from the house Judiciary and then
but Donald Trump still hasn't been like
uh because he was like I met with yay I
didn't know who I didn't know Nick
Fuentes was and then Kanye's like I love
Hitler and Trump's like silent okay well
the thing that he did there was a video
that came out yesterday where he was he
was simping for the Jan Sixers yeah yeah
I showed that I showed that earlier yeah
yeah
of anything you're gonna say not you're
not gonna [ __ ] condemn the person
that just said I like Hitler I love
Hitler like he went on to Alex Jones and
literally said that yeah like he said
that and it's and you look at it why
wouldn't why wouldn't he at this point
we knew it was going to get to this
point right can you
um and then number five of course is uh
Tucker Carlson so I don't know where you
found this but I don't know I mean it's
a it's for the uh the the GOP 2022
wrapped oh yeah you know there's like
the Spotify wrapped but this is like the
GOP right oh my God so who knows maybe
there will be other lists for Jim Jordan
hmm for Matt Gates who knows who knows
it's still 20 22 so it is it is well
let's go to our list which is bone end
of the week everyone stick around we'll
be right back after these messes with
bonehead of the week
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it is Friday
Friday Friday
you know you're on the Tony Michaels
podcast every Friday in the second hour
me and my coach and Sanchez breakdown
the phone end of the week you vote you
decide we break it down of course we got
a lot of great great boneheads this week
never fails with these some [ __ ] and
boy boy did they not disappoint last
night and yesterday holy moly
um it was just on and on and on it went
with the bone-headedry don't you think
yeah non-stop I mean look this is Elon
likes Nazis just because yeah look just
because he suspended uh Kanye on
Twitter does not mean that he's not an
anti-semite and that he does not like
Nazis
and I will make my case later today no
well good good it sounds like you got
something up your sleeve yeah well
nothing but the truth nothing but the
truth and my hate for [ __ ] Nazis stop
these [ __ ] sleeves baby oh my god
well let's do this let's get straight
into the music let's go straight to Bone
end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week where you vote for Mona in the
week you decide we break it down for you
here every single Friday in the second
hour of the Tony Michaels podcast we
broadcast Live on YouTube don't forget
to subscribe and you can vote on YouTube
for bone in the week just go to the
community tab it'll be there sometimes
late sometimes early depending on how
bone-headed these these get these [ __ ]
are and what kind of lists we can build
you can also vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod while uh
I keep saying this why Twitter still
exists but this week's bone end of the
week knows I honestly every day I'm like
maybe it'll be here tomorrow I mean it
will be here's the thing it's December
2nd
Elon has not launched or relaunched
attempted to relaunch his Twitter blue
uh or check mark verification what's
this Twitter check mark blue thing is
this this eight Chan or eight dollar
Chan or it's the Eight dollar Eight
dollar paid for I'm uh I'm someone who's
of Merit yeah blue check mark which will
need other colors now point and laugh at
the Eight dollar checks
um really our bonehead of the week has a
lot to do with Twitter
um this week but let's give the
contestants here we have Kanye West of
course
that's pretty self-explanatory at this
point we have judge Cannon
and she got her decision of the special
Masters struck down by the 11th circuit
so we'll talk about that today and then
Elon Musk the the sole owner and chief
[ __ ] over there at Twitter
um and boy did it show last night
between Kanye West and Elon Musk what
kind of [ __ ] they actually are but
let's start with a different bonehead
let's go with this uh judge Kenneth what
happened yesterday Gabe with judge
Cannon and the decision in the 11th
circuit why is it so important that we
put her on the list what bone-headed
thing did she do and it wasn't yesterday
it was just confirmed yesterday yeah we
just confirmed yesterday it was well if
we go back it's when she started
basically creating new laws or real ways
to interpret the law is this is this a
thing judges can do not that I I don't
think if I remember correctly the you
know role of a judge is to enforce the
law that already exists not interpret
new ways or create new ones rather and
that's what she did with this whole
special Master how are classified
documents handled with the doj that
Trump illegally stole and brought to his
home in Mar-A-Lago and was caught
red-handed because they were literally
in his desk so let me ask you did the
11th circuit buy any of that [ __ ] no
not it no no no no no no now now
apparently
um which I would
surmise here that Trump's going to
appeal and this is going to get to the
Supreme Court my guess is right my guess
is is that the argument at 11 circuit is
going to be the argument that stands
yeah um in that Supreme Court even if
there's one or two dissenters but it's I
mean he's he's he keeps I mean like
every every recent case that's gone to
the Supreme Court right you know and and
we've seen him he's a big loser isn't it
he is a big loser and he attacks me just
like just like Carrie Lake and every
other election denier when they don't
get the results they want they blame the
very group
that they were like hey these people are
going to count it and I'm gonna win and
then when they don't win they blame them
and and Donald Trump did the same thing
he did it previously against the Supreme
Court and called them all a bunch of
hacks went after them on true social
when he doesn't get what he wants he
says that he's the victim I mean
literally during his acceptance speech
for the 2024 campaign he said I'm a
victim I'm a victim said those words he
said those words he wasn't dancing
around it he said it I'm a victim think
about it I'm a victim I'm the victim but
here's the thing and speaking of victims
he's going to be the victim of another
loss here at the Supreme Court
my thing about the special Master is and
it has been since the very beginning
people can go back and look at my
commentary on it I always thought it was
a stall tactic it's all [ __ ] it's
all him trying to Kick the Can a little
further down the road and to stall what
is intimate imminent indictments here
um now we still had this runoff election
and we're probably gonna have to see
this decision this special master case
in the Supreme Court now I'm the lawyer
and everyone here on the mind is touch a
network no I am not I'm not even close
I have to get advice from lawyers but
and sometimes paid sometimes you know
right yeah you got a friend or two but
here's the thing we have a friend here
at the mind of statue Network Ben
mizellis who is an attorney damn good
one and he knows a lot about this stuff
and he does great videos on it and
um
just stay tuned here on the mightiest
Dutch network if you're on the minister
Network page because he's going to keep
you in tune to that but here's my guess
I've always thought it was a stall
tactic and I believe that the Supreme
Court will probably put a stop on the
doj advancing this investigation right I
don't think I think what they're going
to do is take the 11th circuit decision
put a stay on that
um the special Master will stay in place
until they make their decision now how
much time that takes we may get a
Christmas gift because Gabe I really
think the Department of Justice uh when
they appointed the special counsel Jack
Smith this is just my personal opinion I
don't think it was to slow things down I
think it was a speed [ __ ] up and what I
mean by that is they were giving they
knew the time frame here they know
there's there was a runoff they knew
that this process of the special master
was happening
um they're not morons mayor Garland
knows that that process has to play out
and he probably got a good sense of
timing on that which
he was correct the 11th circuit made
their decision yesterday which was
December 1st and I think he was making
sure that Jack Smith was in place and
ready to go when all that nonsense that
stalling and stall tactics are all
played out and it's all out of the way
so that way they can do their job on
this documents case I mean he was I mean
you got to keep it you got to remember
that he was literally working on
Thanksgiving writing a letter with his
uh with his filing motions in the court
and he's like look uh Jim trustee uh
completely wrong the decision that was
here is completely like it's not real
this is not a real thing like the guy
taking time out of his day to work on a
holiday that's typically meant to be
spending eating and spending with you
know watching football or whatever
hanging out with friends and family yeah
but but this guy this guy tries war
criminals and apparently he's oh no for
sure he eats nails and screws for
breakfast I mean this guy does not [ __ ]
around and he does not look like someone
to [ __ ] with to be quite not at all I
mean like he is someone who
who finds the most mundane normal things
of like
super excitement right like this is the
guy that would have fun like correcting
an encyclopedia based on citation right
research it would do it in a very
methodical oh exactly like he would tear
it apart piece by piece yeah and
absolutely destroy why Encyclopedia
Britannica is wrong is that do I have
that right now a long time yeah I I it's
been a long time since I opened an
encyclopedia well you know stamina is a
kid encyclopedia yeah we I mean uh you
know information is crazy so it updates
now it's all electronically yeah it
happens yeah wow what a throwback
um so that is the reason why judge
Cannon now I guess my next question to
you about Judge Cannon is this really
destroys their credibility
it destroys your credibility now I don't
know if she loses her seat on the bench
because of this but I really think it
destroys any other decision that she
makes in the near future oh yeah she
look she made her bed right just like
all these other Nazis in these in these
Republican Nazi sympathizers they made
their bed and what ends up happening is
now they have to lay in it and judge
Eileen Cannon is no different she's a
trump appointed judge thinking hey you
know what I'm gonna pay back the favor
he put me in this position and now
she's [ __ ] made a fool of herself a
laughing stock in the legal Community
within her own group of Judges nobody
will take her seriously and anyone who
sees her decision on paper on a ruling
will probably forever say
I I actually I think I think I'm going
to reread through this and see if uh you
know what hey I'm just gonna challenge
it myself like I feel like judges will
be like uh you know what based on our
history we should probably just like
second guess her ruling and go to the
appeal like nobody like no no lawyer
anywhere else like files it they
themselves as a judge are like ah yeah
you know what
I'm gonna re I'm gonna bring this back
through the system and I think this
needs to be re like ruled on again but
this is what happens when you appoint
unqualified people to judge ships for
the sake of the cult and fascism this is
what happens so let's move on here and
to our next bonehead of the week Elon
Musk now this guy has appeared on bone
end of the week what I think it was good
three weeks three weeks in a row he was
heating up he was on fire he got three
weeks in a row as a dishonorable mention
and this week he found himself
officially on bonehead of the week
because the other one that was like oh
running Twitter and firing people and
all this [ __ ] and was like ah I'm
just gonna let Nazis back on yeah
it was a it was definitely and this past
week really did show that this free
speech absolutist which I think is a
very funny way of describing someone
because they're like look it can only be
this or this like rule like you know oh
the free speech thing and and I I I I
want to go into what Kanye said under
his Banner but right now I want to focus
on Elon and Kanye in the in the back and
forth that they had last night so grab
some links there because I want to be
able to tell the story here because
yesterday we know Kanye West me some
crazy ass statements crazy [ __ ]
statement we were on we were live yeah
and these things were I mean they were
going Beyond because they also had a
four-person panel
after the show ended which so how long
was this Kanye Hitler love fist oh I
don't like was it like three hours or
something [ __ ] it was definitely more
than two and there's a lot of a lot of
Snippets of yeah
within like a 15-20 minute period people
were clipping the things and he had said
Nazi like Hitler love Hitler love what
the Nazis do he said that it was just
like oh we're not well and Alex Jones
was really trying to get it
[Music]
ramp after off ramp after all even Alex
Jones is like yeah you shouldn't be
saying that and I
I won't even say out loud in front of a
microphone that yeah yeah I'll say this
shooting was a hoax but I I won't say
that Hitler was a good guy right right
and I mean it really is something but
the the drama that happened last night
with Elon Musk on Twitter with Kanye
West is something that um it may even be
just a big huge college course in free
speech because oh 100 what and I said
this in the first 30 minutes of the show
these morons like Elon muskanye West and
their simps don't really understand the
difference between hate speech and Free
Speech they just they haven't quite got
it and then what they also don't
understand is that free speech even
though you are not going to be
prosecuted for saying something if it's
free speech you're not you're not free
from the consequences of saying those
things
and again when you're saying something
out loud in public like on a sidewalk
Gabe or on a piece of government
property where you've got the right to
protest when you're saying crazy [ __ ]
out loud you are allowed to say that
stuff but when you're on private
property
you're not always allowed to do whatever
it is that you want yeah because you're
on private property now I've given the
example before you can go and protest
Walmart on the public sidewalk
away from the building with the Sciences
Walmart [ __ ] sucks right and I use
Walmart as an example because they're a
huge company yeah not because I have
something against Walmart a lot of
things
um anyways but what you cannot do you
cannot go on their property take a spray
can
and paint on the side of their building
Walmart [ __ ] sucks that's not a thing
that is not your freedom to do that
that's not your free speech you are on
their private property doing something
that you're it is not free speech the
same way that Kanye cannot post an image
of the Star of David with a swastika
inside of it
on Elon Musk website because he owns it
now it's his yep he owns it so he gets
to say even in a private text message
where they're they're trying to mend
this relationship this this brofist that
they have of this awkward
alternate reality of free speech
where Kanye does this thing with this
image and then Elon bans him now my
question is this uh you got a few links
for me here my question is this do you
believe
that Kanye West
was banned because of the Star of David
swastika image or the image
of Elon Musk which it seems as if Elon
waited till that image popped up but I
mean your personal Take On Me uh I
who knows what's left of the content
moderation team at this point uh so I
don't know who's actually going through
if this was like a Elon personally
flipped a switch or he told someone else
to or someone else did base on a bunch
of reports that people were making
um I don't know man here's here's what
I'll say
he had a tweet that he posted up which
was of the swastika
and he commented on the one photo of
Elon
because it said if I'm going out right
like this would be the last week which
was like wow that's poetic and it is the
last tweet on his account it was the
last I mean I can't even see I can't
even see that I get oh yeah because
because he's still because he suspended
the account like he took the account
yeah so like you can't see it so right
basically
um because because in their text
messages which I want to pull that up to
um in this Elon bit here that we're
doing
um and their text message back and forth
there was actually one where Kanye sends
a screenshot of how he's he's his
account has been locked yeah so that's
I'll I'll do that online because I I
showed that last night because 12 was it
a 12-day lock is what he it was a 12
hour lock twelve hour lock yeah and then
they suspended it um right so if you go
if you if you go to the not this one but
go to the the second link I sent you
this is where it all really started
yesterday so this is the second uh oh
okay this is so this is after
uh Kanye goes on to Alex Jones
says some crazy [ __ ] about how he loves
Hitler like literally like that's how he
said love I like and we're gonna get to
that with the Kanye part of the bonehead
of the week so
he lets Alex Jones write a tweet
and the Tweet was
if you scroll down it says I love the
First Amendment long live yay I pray to
Jesus that Elon is for real that is the
tweet
we watched
there are screenshots that's not part of
the Tweet yeah yeah this is yeah this is
this is a tweet that was sent by Alex
Jones on Kanye's Twitter account they
printed this tweet out
on the show well because Alex Jones
prints everything out like have you ever
watched clips of his show he's got
stacks of [ __ ] papers everywhere so
he because that's that's kind of the bit
that he's done for a long time he takes
Kanye's phone writes this tweet Boop
tweet then they print out the tweet and
Alex Jones signs it
that that it was his right then you
think do you think oh go ahead so this
is right now this is already breaking
the Twitter terms of service you cannot
let other people tweet on your behalf
especially people who have been banned
from the platform especially someone
like Alex Jones who Elon said
specifically was pointed out to be like
you're gonna bring uh Alf Jones back on
and he said no he said no I will not and
it pissed it pissed off a lot of the the
Free Speech Bros out there in the Elon
Simpsons right they really they started
to tuck tail and run towards Kanye so
they've already documented on video on
the show he wrote the tweet for him they
printed out the Tweet he signed it then
this is this Inception like moment where
he tweets a photo of the tweet that was
sent by Alex Jones and signed by Alex
Jones
and Kanye
and put on to Twitter yeah and it says
Jesus is King here now this is this is
elon's response to it yeah so right he
knows he knows what's happened like
there was no way that Elon does not know
or seen clips of Kanye saying I like
Hitler here's the other thing too Nazis
here's the other thing that we find out
they're they're hashing this out in
public on Twitter these two have each
other's cell phone numbers yep they
they're texting I mean we it was safe to
assume but we definitely learned that
last night it would almost be like me
and you get at your other cell phone
numbers it would almost be like us
planning out the show open in Twitter
when we could just do it in a private
text right right exactly it would be
it's it's well I mean it's not the same
but the the the mode of transportation
in the communication would be yeah would
be like I would say one like this way
doing it open in public back and forth
waiting for one person to respond in
this way I look at it as like an in a
like an inefficient way of communication
you know
and also also I think it's positioning
for both these two [ __ ] egomaniacs
right and that that are that are trying
to make sure that they are grabbing a
hold of whatever support that they have
in public right and then they're doing
[ __ ] in private and we're gonna see that
stuff but this is really weird this is
elon's response to the to the Alex Jones
tweet Jesus taught love kindness and
forgiveness he goes on to say I used to
think that turning the other treat was
weak and foolish
but I was the fool for not appreciating
its profound wisdom so literally
the the anti-semites are tweeting uh
like you said Alex Jones is not supposed
to be tweeting from someone else's
account
um that is a violation of terms of
service for for Kanye to even let him
tweet from his account
um and they're tweeting [ __ ] like this
right yep and then Elon responds with
Jesus this Jesus that I mean that's
basically not hey you know there's
really I will say this I don't know what
it is uh maybe there's just like a
complete disconnect of reality but I've
noticed and I'm sure other people as
well as yourself have seen that people
who are like crazy conspiracy theorists
and and whatnot they they really attach
to religion misinterpret religion for
sure right and misinterpret the they
re-aster they oh 100 but it's all these
people are like oh take the you know red
pill this red pill that get woke wake up
all this [ __ ] oh I saw Jesus and God
and he told me to do this and do that
and it's like why are all you [ __ ]
nut jobs who believe in this cult-like
mentality these conspiracy theories
resort to religion right they're all the
same and Elon Musk is another one of
them never did I ever think that Elon
Musk of all people would have said oh
yeah I'm a Jesus loving [ __ ] guy
right I love that guy yeah never would I
ever thought he's not religious he's not
it's a it's an app right just like this
where it's he's still Tweeting from his
eyes I thought he had a Tesla phone what
the [ __ ] why is he still Tweeting from
his iPhone I don't know I'm just trying
to ask okay so this next that the one
that I had up but we're gonna go to it
next um it actually shows what started
the process of Kanye getting suspended
here this was the one that in the
private text thread that they have Elon
says this is way too far yeah he said
this is yeah too far this is uh
uh right well we're gonna get to that
yeah but this is a screenshot of the
Tweet because we can't go look at the
Tweet
um and again it's from Kanye West
account see that Kanye West that's Kanye
West
um ye 24 love everyone oh my God hashtag
Love Speech
and he posts this image
um I don't know where this is it says
it's on Photoshop so someone is
photoshopping somebody it's on Photoshop
the file is called yay 24 dot whatever
uh I don't know if he made this or
someone else made this I have no idea
but I'm sure I'm not scared to show it
I'm not going to show it because we need
to see what the hell he was posting on
his account and and obviously it is the
Star of David with a swastika
intertwined with it yeah um and the
suggestions are you know there's
numerous suggestions here but the main
suggestion is is that
Jewish people are Nazis yep right I I
believe that's the overall suggestion
that Kanye West was trying to say here
and he was trying to prove that he can
post it
um because there's free speech well love
speech right because because free
speeches
it can't be hate speech right and that's
my point earlier in the episode is that
hate speech is not free speech they are
not the same types of speech
um now
this image here is probably highly
offensive to a lot of people right now
there are people out there who try to
justify this because
um Hitler appropriated the swastika yep
in the symbol swashka and by doing that
and doing what he did he changed the
meaning of it I don't give a [ __ ] what
the meaning of it was before it was
complete appropriation and the meaning
has now changed and that symbol does not
mean what you want it to mean people who
are trying to justify this image so I
just want to start there yeah but this
is not where The Saga of this image end
ends I think this is this next uh link
that you sent me right
um this is where they have the back and
forth right so this is one of the No No
so this is no this that's the last
that's the last one okay so so let's
finalize let's go there can you find me
the text messaging yeah yeah um because
that's that's what that's the one thing
I want to see now these are screenshots
from from Kanye West account as you you
can see here Kanye West this is the very
last tweet that was posted before he was
suspended
um it says let's always remember this is
my final tweet hashtag a24 and it's the
image of uh uh a tubby Elon Musk being
hosed off by I don't know who who this
guy is uh Elon actually said his name in
in a tweet somewhere
um but hosing him off on a yacht right
um apparently Elon does not like this
image I can't understand why you
wouldn't like it I mean it's him right
yeah and it shows that he's Superior I
mean he's got someone else to hose him
off I mean and it definitely shows that
he's white for sure
um so you know I don't know why he
wouldn't like this image but he
apparently does not like this image yeah
and here is the result
uh well at least what it appears to be
the result
after that the timing was very odd but
also the other thing too is
the Tweet had been so the original tweet
that we had shown was the symbol with
the symbol had been taken down
it had already been taken down yeah
because he it it said that it violated
Twitter's rules right so either Elon or
someone else at Twitter pulled that
tweet down or hit him came in after the
fact
and commented it was like this is not
okay right because he was like he said
the photo of him on the boat's like this
is fine this is okay this is this is not
okay but then was called out and like
wait wait why are you commenting on the
fact that like it's not okay after it
was taken down right like you're coming
in and trying to play this person of
like oh that's not okay
but the time stamps show a very
different story right and he was getting
called out for which is I I believe I
believe I believe he knew he was in
trouble when Kanye went on
and went on Alex Jones and said what he
said I believe this was in full freak
out mode right because because what
people have been accusing Elon of elon's
been saying no it's not hate speech it's
free speech he's been really he's been
really digging in his heels about the
difference between hate speech and free
speech and he really doesn't have a good
definition of hate speech and that is
the problem with Twitter right now is it
is loaded with [ __ ] Nazis everywhere
yeah um and people feel like it's free
reign over there because of Elon not not
it's because of Elon now when Kanye West
I believe
and we're going to show the clips here
in a minute because
um as you know he's our bonehead
um that was pretty easy uh we knew that
was going to happen yesterday when we
played the clip but when Elon heard
Kanye say these things into a microphone
he knew he was in [ __ ] trouble
because he gave Kanye's account back
after he knew he'd post anti-Semitism he
knew he's an anti-semite he continued
down that road he gave him his account
back he kept he kept at it and kept at
it and kept at it and he finally said
the thing that was just too much for
anybody
and and you could tell I could tell that
Elon was probably really concerned that
hey now I'm gonna be known as a Nazi
right because you are if again I don't
know how many times I have to say this
if there is a Nazi eating at a table and
there's 10 other people eating and
having fun with that Nazi there are 11
Nazis at that table there is 11 Nazis
not one 11. so when you're eating at the
table with a bunch of [ __ ] Nazis just
be clear when we call you one that's
because you are um but here is
and this is eating at the table with a
Nazi because here's the uh images of
their their uh is this their text this
is their text but no I don't know yes
this is this is him this is him
acknowledging the fact that this is yay
posting the images that's how we have
these images yeah so this is him posting
the text message between him and Elon
and this is how he knows it's at least
he's on the verge of losing the account
right
because Elon says and let me see if I
can uh go to the uh other image here
here's the one image
from Elon Musk right this is what we're
assuming this is from Elon Musk but the
timing works out to where it's more than
likely Elon Musk says sorry but you've
gone too far this is not love and he's
posting the image and
okay like this should tell you
everything you need to know about how
Elon looks at these things right
he says this is too far this is not love
first off the fact that he would even
give Kanye the just the the moment of
his time to text him shows you exactly
what Elon believes
right he believes that he needs to give
someone a heads up and say hey that's
not cool man you can't be posting these
very vulgar images in the sense of like
you're you're sharing a swastika inside
the Star of David you know the history
why why would you do this
yeah but I'm gonna push back on you a
bit there I don't think it's actually I
don't think elon's concerned about the
image I think elon's concerned about his
because oh no yeah he's like whoa you're
you are going to put me in a position
where I have to defend a schwash to
command that is not a position I want to
be in Elon will defend a bunch of Nazi
Bots all day long those are just Bots
this is Kanye West I mean how there's
like 32 million people that follow that
[ __ ] on on his platform right I
think it's 32 and then on uh on Twitter
on Twitter yeah
so he's putting Elon gave him his
account back it is not like Elon Elon
just inherited a Twitter where Kanye
West wasn't suspended he gave him his
account back and then this [ __ ]
is doing exactly what everyone said that
that these [ __ ] would do yeah
this is they will put hate speech up
Elon if you do this and they're doing
exactly they're doing exactly
when he brought when he brought uh Kanye
back right he goes testing testing
seeing if it's working
Elon posted in responded was like hey
what's up you know right and
and the the intentional use of the word
that he that that Kanye posted was
Shalom right which with a wink face
right which is gross because he knows
exactly what he's doing he's trying to
be tongue-in-cheek and make a joke at
the expense of Jewish people
to be like oh man I was going Defcon 3
on those people fake Gabe that's what he
said and that's what he meant
uh is everyone why he was suspended
by the actual moderation team by the
moderation the head of trust and safety
in the moderation team right the reason
why the UK was okay with Twitter but
they're not going to be okay with
Twitter soon yeah that's a whole other
thing I'd love to get into later but
this is one of those things where he
comes back on he goes wink and then says
shalom
the guy has no no reason like he's not
going to change his ways
he he said what he said he did what he
did he meant what he said and he did and
he's not gonna change and be like oh you
know what now that I'm back on I won't
be anti-semitic well here you see him
he's going to be you see it in this text
right here because this is the response
right here from Kanye West too this is
the Free Speech absolute as being
questioned who made you the judge well I
mean frankly honestly as much as I don't
like it Elon Musk owns yeah Twitter he
gets to decide what goes on and what
doesn't go on so he is the judge
ultimately he's a sole owner he doesn't
have to answer to anybody not even Kanye
West so yeah he is the judge it's his
[ __ ] website friend so that's what
makes him the judge their their sport
but it just shows you that
it is it is
it is
Kanye West's position
that he gets to be an anti-semite
whenever and wherever he wants no matter
what because it is his entitlement to do
that it is not your entitlement you're
not entitled to any space you want to be
a bigot and do spread eight speech
that's not your entitlement that's not a
thing it just doesn't exist and for Elon
Musk to play footsie with this [ __ ] and
really frankly I truly believe that that
it is probably the symbol that led Elon
to go okay this is the last straw but it
did it was kind of funny that in the end
uh Kanye kind of digged him on the
picture because he you know I
I'll say this when they actually took
that tweet down they should have just
locked his account and suspended him
um they didn't do that not even close
what's this uh that you're saying oh
here
just another screenshot okay so yeah
this is this is where
um so after he says who made you the
judge [ __ ] Elon Musk
in pure alt-right style who appropriates
religion like you were saying earlier
start stop type out the Lord's Prayer
the Our father right Our Father who art
in heaven Hallowed be our name the king
of Canada will be done
as it is in heaven
and obviously Kanye liked or loved it
yeah love it love the religion there
guys I'm Jesus name I'm not really sure
I think he meant to say in Jesus name
amen okay that makes sense that makes
yeah that makes sense in Jesus name but
then he posts this
um which is an image of
and it's not it's not it's yeah it
locked this isn't a suspension I saw
someone else say oh it was a 12-hour ban
it's a restriction on his account he got
yeah he can't tweet but there's limited
functionality that you can have
basically you can like you can like DM I
think you can like
so you can't follow anyone
um you can't you can you can DM people I
believe
um and there's a few other functions
that you can't have right uh but so at
this point he has a 12-hour uh temporary
restriction and that this was this was
after this is probably as a result of
them taking down that tweet right yeah
yeah and it wasn't just that tweet
because here's the thing the tweet that
he shared then also because this text
message right now was shared on Truth
social so if you go to the next image
that I shared in there uh boom it's in
the thread
here's the true social so this is this
is this is so true social right verify
this his account he joined in November
right after Thanksgiving
and now he's posting that text that that
screenshot that we just showed and
saying standing with the j6ers as we
speak Jesus's King hashtag what does
this have to do with January 6th yeah
I'm gonna safely assume that it's the uh
certain rights have been taken away from
people that were trying to do very bad
things and Connie's like I'm also one of
them I'm a victim
right and all these people who are like
I'm a victim oh this is funny I'm
getting canceled you literally said it
you said that you knew it was bad to say
you said it and it's not canceled
it's [ __ ] consequences you said
something that you shouldn't say and
people said not for me and they either
reported you
or they called you out
you're not the victim well um
perpetrator I'd say if he's truly was
canceled if he truly was cancer our
dishonorable mention would not have had
him on on on his show if he truly was
canceled exactly and um because he had
the ability to go in front of a
microphone remember the private property
thing I was talking about Alex Jones
owns a studio and he owns a website and
he posts a lot of vile [ __ ] there and
yesterday he did the same thing and gave
the opportunity for Kanye West here's
one clip of it we're gonna watch a few
of them but here's Alex Jones here's our
dishonorable mention and really he's a
dishonorable mention because he actually
allowed Kanye West to say this [ __ ]
right and I don't know if Alex Jones is
just like he's like you know what just
let him say it I actually believe it's
because Alex Jones is a lot of financial
trouble here because 175 billion that's
a lot of [ __ ] money and apparently
he's filed bankruptcy which is not going
to uh do any good when it comes to that
billion dollars
um but I believe uh Alex Jones is trying
to attract an audience here and that's
the reason why all these [ __ ] idiots
like Temple are having these
anti-semites in these Nazis on their
show but again you set a table with
Nazis you're a Nazi but listen to listen
to this this back and forth this is just
21 seconds of this couple hours of
Hitler loving but let's listen I don't
think Hitler was a good guy I get the uh
the Hugo Boss uniforms amazing uh but I
mean just because you're in love with
the design you're a designer can we just
kind of say like you like the you like
the uniforms but that's about it oh we
we no there's a lot of things that I
love about Hitler
a lot of things
okay
um okay this is this is what this is why
Alex Jones is the dishonorable mention
because Alex Jones owns those
microphones he owns that broadcast he
could have shut that off whenever he
wanted anything he could have called him
out even more because what he did there
this is just one [ __ ] moment this was
this was a this was like 21 seconds
if P I'm sure people can find the rest
of the videos on Twitter they are just
as gross and and humiliating in terms of
what people stand for
but the idea that he was allowed to be
on that show he knew he knew Kanye was
going to do some crazy [ __ ] now whether
he knew he was going to say I love
Hitler and I love what Hitler did and we
should stop dissing the Nazis not sure
about that one but even when those
moments happened on Alex Jones's show
Infowars he tried to give Kanye the
benefit of the doubt which
is already doing a lot
he tried to say oh you know what I get
it
you like the Hugo Boss uniforms yeah
they're great love them
but but Hitler and the Nazis let's let's
let's let's draw a line here where we
say that we should not sympathize for
them and say that they were the ones who
are the victims
and then Kanye responds and says no I
love
Hitler I love what he did he said stop
dissing the Nazis I like Hitler I love
Hitler he also said that you know all
humans are should have right at the
table right for things even especially
especially the word expression
especially Hitler yeah the other crazy
[ __ ] that that that is twisted up and
and you know a lot we talked about this
yesterday about bipolarism and people
taking advantage and I think I think
Alex Jones Miley Annapolis Temple
um Nick Fuentes Donald Trump they're all
taking advantage of Kanye here
um but the people want to blame it on
his bipolar and I don't know if this is
an act or something like that or this is
an attempt of self-destruction I'm not
really sure but the fact of the matter
is is that Kanye West is doing this
himself no one is forcing him no one's
holding him down to say these things he
is saying this [ __ ] he even said
delusional [ __ ] like Hitler and Bennett
highways and stuff yeah stuff that is
way [ __ ] way away from whatever
reality right like
you you get in a situation where you're
trying to justify the Holocaust by
denying it
um is one thing but when you actually
believe that that Hitler invented
highways you are on some [ __ ] Next
Level Playing delusion with [ __ ] I know
and yeah and it's also somebody say like
you know I I saw fake Gabe and you know
oh yeah of course oh well we knew we had
mental problems yeah sure yeah he was
bipolar right he had bipolar right but
that but yeah but but most almost all
bipolar people don't run around saying
they love Hitler it's not that's not
it's that's not a [ __ ] symptom of
bipolarism it is
deeply rooted yes deeply rooted that he
himself has he has he said those things
right he has this hatred towards a group
of people that he has generalized for
them all being bad
and the problem is
at the core of it he's anti-semitic
right that's what he is and and his his
mental illness and whether people are
taking advantage of him in certain ways
right right he has a platform to to
platform themselves with their own idea
well I think it's important I think it's
more is money than oh yeah yeah no no I
mean I I definitely I mean I mean they
definitely love the idea that they have
this very famous very well-known black
man saying [ __ ] into a microphone that
supports white supremacy and that is the
thing that really pushes their message
right but also with Milo and Nick and
it's right about money because parlor
did the same thing parlor's like ooh we
really want Kanye's money and then after
yesterday like maybe not yeah right
maybe we don't want the hitches which is
ironic because the person that helped
negotiate and push that deal through was
Candace Owens she created she bolstered
she she and they were wearing the White
lives matter sweatshirts at the Fashion
things on you know sheep because the way
I look at it is like he his deeply
rooted anti-semitic views that is a
truth that that is an absolute right
there right that is that is the that is
the thing that cannot be denied
you probably have a guy that's already
paranoid because of a history of of
Paparazzi people invading his privacy
all this stuff doesn't help when you
already have a mental illness especially
bipolar
he's going through an episode we can
assume right it's a longer episode but
we assume that he's not on medication
has no control you've got people that
are taking advantage of those
insecurities that paranoia being like Oh
Jewish people are coming to get you this
and that they're coming here they're
coming there Candice Owens who already
has this pro-white anti-black uh
anti-everything else kind of uh way of
thinking takes advantage she pushes him
she she she accelerates she it's like
she's [ __ ] basically Candace Owens
lit a match she threw kerosene on
something right anti-Semitism and and
the story here is is that she is the
wife of the CEO of parlor right right
and that's and that's where this part of
the thing came about and and they dumped
it yesterday now I I want to move on
here and I know it's a little bit of a
turn and then we're gonna turn back
because the alpha [ __ ] really doesn't
have much to do with the uh the Kanye
story
um but it kind of does in power politics
Newt Gingrich apparently this morning
he's the alpha cuck of the week and the
reason why is he is he is getting cocked
by the Republicans I believe because
they're not listening to him at all
um Newt Gingrich
did he write in did he say something is
there a clip of it or did he just write
this
um but he basically is saying he's
warning the Republican party not to
underestimate uh Joe Biden yeah and
here's the reason why I don't know if
anyone watched yesterday as as even Ted
Cruz voted for this uh paid lead the
sick leave
um bill that's being pushed through to
keep the railroads open but um Joe Biden
has been in Washington for a long time
like that's one of the things they say
oh it's horrible about him he's a career
politician but here's the thing
Joe Biden better is better at counting
votes than almost anyone in Washington
and that is more obvious now more than
ever he knows and he even said it the
other day and I believe it was um
I forget what issue it was Gabe that he
was talking about and he said look I
we've got to count the votes he said it
out loud we gotta count the votes Joe
Biden knows that there might not be [ __ ]
he can do with the senate or the house
if he can't get the votes he's got to
have the votes to get some things done
and because he knows that he's a great
uh he whips votes very well right and he
knows who to go to and how to do that
and the reason why is because the guy
was in the senate for so long the guy
knows the process he knows and and
that's what I think Newt gingers is
warning the Republicans is this a clip
of it uh this is this because so it's
not him talking about it this is him
writing about it so that's what that's
what I thought it was yeah I didn't
think it actually and I just want to I
just want to tag on to that point that
he made about uh Joe Biden is you know
Republicans are like oh sleepy Joe Biden
he's been in office for 47 years too
long blah blah politician
the guy knows how to get [ __ ] done and
he's proven that by pushing through and
working with on both sides of the aisle
he's may not be the he may not get the
majority of Republicans but he gets a
few here and there that he's able to get
these wins and these wins are proving to
help Americans right
and the only people that are standing in
the way are Republicans and so it really
is this moment of Republicans must learn
to quit underestimating President Joe
Biden well here here is Newt Gingrich on
his own website or is this his website
okay so this is his website he he posts
Republicans must learn to quit
underestimating President Joe Biden the
reason why I want him the alpha [ __ ] of
the week is because he's getting kicked
by the Republicans already today they're
already underestimating Joe Biden which
is on brand for them which I hope they
continue to do just like I hope they
they keep bolstering this Fascism and
saying the quiet part Out Loud Like Mike
Flynn Carrie late Donald Trump
saying these things out loud so we know
who the [ __ ] they are and which ones are
which and who are the Nazis so we can
make sure they're not to put them in
power and I I want to spend a little
more time on Newt Gingrich but we gotta
go we gotta go back to the candidates oh
boy for bone of the week and we know we
know who the winner is I knew as soon as
I seen the clip yesterday where Kanye
West is talking about Hitler I knew in
the moment that he was going to be the
bone net of the week
there was no question and I mean his
fate was sealed as soon as he said his
uh his admiration and love for Hitler
and the Nazis and was sympathizing and
saying that we should not be dissing the
Nazis anymore when you see a person say
that and it is on TV it is [ __ ] on
live broadcast
their fate is sealed this person is no
longer someone who can who can crawl
back and redeem himself in the hearts of
the general population the things that
this guy has said and the things that he
has done so far and spewing his
anti-semitic rhetoric across Twitter
truth social on on podcasts and other
shows and interviews
the guy's done and he most certainly 100
percent
just deserves his position as bonehead
of the week
uh full stop now I want to show I'm
trying to find a clip oh yeah here it is
this is it
okay this is the clip we showed
yesterday now the context of this
because Alex Jones streams this live
right and until on his website and until
it's really finished streaming you can't
really download it yeah you can't so you
gotta you gotta be clipping grab yeah
and uh right wing watch is the one who
posted this clip that we showed
yesterday now they were able to pull it
because
um you see down here in the corner
there's a streamer here his name is uh
Vincent James right he's a white
nationalist he's a Nazi and he loves
what Kanye is doing here by the way yeah
very excited you'll see his reaction but
I actually think this clip puts more
context to why this [ __ ] is
saying this [ __ ] and why Alex Jones is
having Nick Fuentes who is a known Nazi
and Kanye West on his show I think this
does a better job than just the clip
itself I think this clip is way more
important in the context of Republican
politics than just the clip itself this
is super important because this is the
same guy who was on Clips the other day
saying that hey we control the messaging
now which they do Nick Fuentes and these
[ __ ] boneheads control the Republican
messaging they are the GOP establishment
now and these are their opinions no
matter how much they want to denounce
they have they have owned this Hook Line
sinker and I'll show you a tweet that
they they they've been owning it and Jim
Jordan deleted but here is
here's this clip yesterday where he says
especially Hitler let's listen you're
not Hitler you're not a Nazi you don't
deserve to be called that a demonized
well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also okay I'm gonna stop there because
yesterday we pointed this out basically
Alex Jones is really trying to give him
an out here now rather Alex Jones knew
exactly what Kanye was going to say or
not he's giving him an out and this is
not the only time he tried to give him
an out there multiple clips across the
internet you can find on Twitter and
other places Alex is trying to trying to
get him to say no I don't like him he's
like ah like okay like I'll agree with
some stuff but talking insane Hitler's
nice and we should defend him not a
thing that he's this is the guy this is
the guy who demonized little children
being murdered in a school in
Connecticut and then demonize their
parents and act like it was all fake and
they were actor all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
but he's not willing to go here
um but but the thing that gets me the
most is when Alex Jones is trying to
signal to Kanye on a live stream because
when we're sitting on the live stream me
and Gabriel were remote I can send him a
message if like we got a problem or
something I can talk to him in the
background that is not the situation
that is happening right here Alex Jones
is signaling on a live stream
hey man don't say Nazis are good and
Hitler's good you say you're not a Nazi
say you're not Hitler and immediately
the first word that pops into Kanye's
brain when when Alex Jones says you're
not a Nazi is well well I mean maybe
yeah right maybe I mean it's it's
[ __ ] weird man that's being weird the
the tone of the well is the same thing
you hear from someone's like well let's
uh if I were to play racist but I'm not
racist or like if I were to play Devil's
Advocate on this it's like there is no
Devil's Advocate there is no devil down
Hitler bad the absolute if you want to
be a free speech absolutist the the
absolute free speech and truth about
this is that he was bad Nazis were bad
we are in full agreement that what they
did was horrific there was no way to be
like well we should think about this one
thing he did things just popped in my
brain it's so funny and the reason why
it's hilarious is because even in our
chat like fake Gabe and Jeremy Johnson
say we're murders and we murder babies
and all this [ __ ] right and and oh we're
despicable we're demons but here's Kanye
West and they're going to to do this
whole gymnastics to justify through Free
Speech mind you through free speech of
justifying that Kanye thinks a a
murderous [ __ ] dictator who who
committed genocide on six million Jewish
people
they're gonna do gymnastics to justify
that right but oh you talk you talk
about a mut one mother having to save
her life with a medical procedure that's
murder yeah but it just it's [ __ ]
weird that the pro-lifers are on Kanye's
side here but let's let's listen
Jewish people are not going to tell me
[ __ ] you can oh my God now you hear the
guy in the background the excitement
that's actually Vincent James yeah
that's why I think this is so important
in the moment is because really I mean
honestly there's a lot of people that
say this stupid [ __ ] online I've had it
in Threads you get it in DMS and and
I've seen it a lot is Hitler this Hitler
that I love Hitler you know you can find
that [ __ ] especially on some of these
other toxic social media websites like
parlor like uh like true social like gab
telegram all these deep dark parts of
the web H and 4chan but what is so
significant here and why Vincent James
is so [ __ ] excited is because it's
not some [ __ ] Rando on a thread
saying it and posting an image right it
is [ __ ] Kanye West someone who has 32
million Twitter followers he has a huge
following all around the world he's
black
he's a black man saying [ __ ] using using
the message of white supremacists and
Nazis out of his mouth into a microphone
that's what excitement said James you're
almost to a Goddamn orgasm yeah
um and that's why they're excited it has
nothing to do with the actual words they
believe the words yeah they believe the
words they're just excited that their
messaging has worked its way into
Kanye's mouth and into a microphone on
like Alex Jones's show that's what
they're excited about listen
um you know us and you can love what
we're doing to you with the concert
because he's really laughing at Kanye
here yeah we're pushing with the
pornography but this guy that invented
highways invented the very microphone
that I use as a musician you can't say
out loud that this person ever did
anything good and I'm done with that I'm
done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table so true
especially Hitler you're
and of course Vincent James is excited
about this and when he's laughing
he's laughing at Kanye yeah Vincent
James cannot even [ __ ] fathom that
their white supremacy that their Nazi
message has worked its way into Kanye
West mouth into a microphone that is
going to be disseminated to millions of
people which you should watch it uh I I
I knocked Don Lemon earlier because
everyone was saying Don Lemon owned
Kanye West on CNN no he did not Don
Lemon is a weak piece of [ __ ] in that
clip because he wouldn't show the
[ __ ] clip they won't show that Kanye
said this [ __ ] show it you [ __ ]
people are not that weak people can see
this and go that is a bunch of [ __ ]
bigotry and hatred and it should be and
we should not tolerate that [ __ ] you can
see it and not tolerate it it's [ __ ]
ridiculous that everyone has to think
that Americans are so weak it's the
[ __ ] that we have
um so this is one clip of this
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] show that went on
for a long time yesterday I think a lot
of people were watching this live and
trying to figure out you know and I
think actually can you go to that
Michael Rapaport clip yeah because it
you know Michael Rapaport has been going
back and forth with Kanye uh Michael
Rapaport people don't know is Jewish uh
so this obviously hits uh on a personal
note for him but this was this was him
in response to this whole crazy
anti-semitic visit that he did on
Infowars
um and he makes a pretty good point in
this in this little uh response all
right so let's watch there's no coming
back scumbag Kanye West
you miserable [ __ ] [ __ ] mask
wearing [ __ ] you're sitting
there talking to a person who God forbid
your kids
were in that classroom in Sandy Hook he
denied
that that happened that's where you're
at
and you're bringing up
the most despicable person ever and
saying there's good in him
in a [ __ ] mask
you think that Adolf Hitler wouldn't
have thrown your ass in an oven or shot
you in the street and not even thought
twice about it you dumb [ __ ]
there's no good in him and at this point
I believe
what was good in you is gone and your
mother God rests her soul would be a
shame to you your mother would have been
ashamed of you and what you've become
you [ __ ] you
uh he makes all good points there
um I mean there's not a point that he
wasn't on and usually Michael Rapaport
is straight on point and I know he does
a lot of stuff on sports and
entertainment and stuff
um but I I actually feel his
authenticity in that in that clip there
right I'm sure Michael has met Khan
ain't talked to him personally in person
before yeah um but ever since this whole
thing went down he called him out and
was like no no don't you know you
shouldn't be saying this is not what's
okay you know especially as like a rise
in in hate crimes against Jewish people
has has come up like well Michael
Rapaport made the video that prompted me
to have a conversation with you because
I I had no clue I I just didn't know
when Michael Rapaport made the video
said hey if you're not Jewish you can't
say juice stop saying that stop saying
that and it prompted me to because I was
kind of like whoa should I check myself
and I checked with you and and I thought
about it and I think it's appropriate to
check myself on on because I'm not a
Jewish person right right I'm not and
it's I should check myself
um because I kind of compared it in our
conversation and the reason why I ask
you is because a lot of people feel like
Mexican is a derogatory term it's like
well not really and that's why it's that
conversation that I said I don't think
Jews is a derogatory term but it
definitely in your point that you made
and I think Michael was making in that
video not this one but another one is
that it's the context and how you're
saying it right right it it really
matters because they use that word in a
derogatory sense that it doesn't matter
how you use it right and also used in it
you know in the tone negatively
especially around when you're talking
about a holocaust right right the
Holocaust that was you know put against
them by this terrible man that con not
even a man but a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that is Hitler and you've got Kanye West
on Infowars saying oh you know what I
love Hitler Hitler did great things
especially Hitler we should stop dissing
The you know it's one of those things
that you have to stop and like what like
what reality what what [ __ ] Bizarro
timeline are we living in where we're
letting these people go on and say these
things right or or letting them continue
to say these things and it's because and
it really is it comes down to the fact
the Republican Party supports
anti-Semitism they did not have a
problem with Kanye saying all of these
things before about oh I could do some
anti-semitic [ __ ] and Adidas can't stop
me that tweet that [ __ ]
uh Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan put up onto Twitter from
the GOP Judiciary uh Twitter account
that said uh Kanye Elon Trump
period period period Kanye Elon Trump
I've seen some other editions that says
Kanye Elon Trump Hitler which is a very
accurate uh tweet to have out there well
I mean now and I don't know if they made
that before but if they made that before
it was oh yeah where we're going to end
up it really is again it comes down to
the fact that Republicans are okay with
anti-Semitism as soon as somebody says
Hitler and not right yeah say that out
loud yeah then they say oh no no no
that's that's still a quiet part yeah
and that I think that is the most
important thing but I want people to
remember about the politicization of
this right Kanye is not a republican
he's not he's an anti-semite right we we
he has well established that and if he
if no one understands the
well-establishment of that in the last
24 hours you have not been paying
attention right but the fact of the
matter is is that the quiet part out
loud has now been said and I almost bet
you're gonna have more Republic looking
setting Republicans justifying this
Hitler talk and Hitler is good
um from them you're just gonna see it
because now look now at the cat's out of
the bag and and now we know so let's do
that and if anyone and I and I and I do
want to point out for anyone out there I
saw a comment that somebody was like uh
uh oh and for context yes they they took
down that tweet they posted that Tweet
back in uh
um it was 56 days ago so two months
prior they had it up for the whole time
that Kanye went on his whole
anti-semitic press tour only until he
said I love Hitler and as soon as he
said I love Hitler on Alex Jones
Infowars yesterday boom it got deleted
that was the thing they were like oh
well we can't publicly say this we
support them but we can't publicly say
it well this is the thing this was the
thing that was the too much out loud of
the quiet here it is I don't think
Hitler was a good guy I get the uh the
Hugo Boss uniforms amazing uh but I mean
just because you're in love with the
design you're a designer can we just
kind of say like you like the you like
the uniforms but that's about it oh we
we no I there's a lot of things that I
love about Hitler
a lot of things
that's it there's the bonehead of the
week in his moment Kanye West is our
winner Gabe Sanchez let's give him his
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh Kanye Kanye Kanye you bonehead you
bonehead of the week congratulations on
your your full flight to full-on
anti-Semitism I think that clip uh let
me go back to it here because I want to
show you something in this clip you're
going to talk about Nick Fuentes yeah
look look how excited he is giddy he is
excited not in his head I mean oh my God
these are the people that Kanye West is
surrounding himself with you've got this
guy clearly yep looking in front his oh
yeah oh yeah everything he said Is Right
everything he said is right it's [ __ ]
gross it's it's it's disgusting and the
fact again the fact that it's [ __ ]
2022 okay World War II was not like a
hundred and two hundred years ago no it
was within the last century okay the
last generation yeah Jesus it's quite
like oh my God it is it is it is insane
to think that we live in the year 2022
it is [ __ ] December we're coming up
on the holidays and this is what we have
to deal with this is instead of dealing
with actual problems
we have to deal with this [ __ ] idiot
going on to other shows and doing a
whole press Tour on other shows and
saying how Hitler was good and the Nazis
we should stop dissing them and and
anti-Semitism is cool and all of this
[ __ ] well I mean several weeks ago
we were doing this at this dance on the
show about Kanye West going on some some
obscure podcast it scared I mean it's
like the beers and something oh the
drink Champs and he was like black
people are Jews right that's what he was
saying he was saying that [ __ ] and then
Jewish and now he's like Hitler I love
Hitler which is a whole nother [ __ ]
another animal it's just it's crazy that
we can't even
and this is Republican politics and
that's why you watch the show so we will
show you because we will not shy away
from giving sunlight as the best
disinfectant here on the attorney
Michael's podcast subscribe so you can
watch bonehead of the week every single
week and the Friday if you're on the
minus touch Channel subscribe there if
you're watching this and also
every single Friday we do this on the
Tony Michaels podcast and the mind of
such Network we have the clip every
single Friday every single one of them
and here's how you vote Gabe you go to
Twitter and you follow at Tony Michael's
pod you can vote there every Thursday
you can also vote again on our YouTube
channel just go to the Tony Michaels
podcast YouTube channel go to to the
community tab you can vote there also
download every single episode and watch
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast Apple Spotify Google
oh man what a bonehead whoosh I I I have
to say we've been doing this bonehead
thing for a year now and this is
probably the biggest bonehead the
biggest boneheaded thing that we've had
these entire time and we've had a lot of
bonus it is they've done a lot of stupid
[ __ ] I mean I'll tell you this much it's
last December we had the let's go
Brandon phenomenon that started right
right and soon after that you had the
Nazis right over they were draping over
the curtains and and sheets on the
expressway on the highway uh that Hitler
did not create and and was saying let's
go Brandon and then head swastikas like
it this whole idea that this [ __ ] keeps
happening around the holidays like I
don't know if it's just a coincidence or
what but the idea that these people keep
thinking that they can they can make
this a normal occurrence they can
normalize this we need to call it out at
every moment that we can and like
everyone know and let everyone know they
have the finger call them out call them
what they really are if there is
sympathizer they're a Nazi again like
Tony was saying earlier you've got 10
people at a at a table and one of them
is a Nazi you have 11 [ __ ] Nazis
that's what it is right you see it you
call it out you know see something say
something
well we all keep calling it out here on
bone in the week and Johnny Michaels
podcast everyone
stick around we have messages right
after this
[Music]
[Applause]
bone-in of the week oh that was a land
transmission
it happens bone of the week I cannot
believe that uh that clip um again I
don't know if it's a performance or not
with Kanye I don't really give a [ __ ]
there's no there's there is no way there
was no bipolarism you said mean that you
had to ban
um Jeremy Johnson I
I said earlier Jeremy Johnson went the
way of well the
uh okay Jeremy Johnson went the way of
being pro-nazi in the chat so here's
here's the thing here's the thing is
that
um we will tolerate trolls we will
tolerate Trolls but we will not we will
not we will not tolerate Nazi Ducks
pushing racism
buddy you're gone gone so poor Jeremy
Johnson I'm I'm I'm kind of sad to see
him go but [ __ ] you Nazi [ __ ] you
um so uh Gabe this has been our first
full week back from the Thanksgiving
break but I want to remind everyone
who's still with this because these are
these are the loyal Watchers the ones at
the very end that want to hear the last
final [ __ ] them
um every single day and the Surf's Up so
here's the thing is that we we took a
Thanksgiving break it was a great break
you were you got a little sick though
over that weekend yeah yeah yeah
I think I caught I got whatever you had
you gave me yeah you know I didn't want
to say anything but I think it's just
you wanted an extra prolonged break oh
yeah I don't blame you I don't blame you
I don't believe but here's the thing
we're gonna take a Christmas break we
haven't I think we've decided but we
haven't made it official yet yeah of
what days so we will take a Christmas
break we also take a New Year's Break
um during those holidays but we will be
here I just want to give people a heads
up and uh maybe we'll maybe we'll post
that next week and start talking about
that so everyone knows because I believe
on Christmas
um that Christmas vacation we won't have
a bonehead that week like we didn't on
Thanksgiving so we will not have a
because of how that I mean we could run
a poll again
but we won't we won't do that we won't
do the show so um everyone we will let
you know hopefully starting next week of
how that schedule is going to play out
so you know what days uh we are and are
not on so that you're not uh worried
about us or looking for us on those days
um for those holidays and we appreciate
you sticking with us even through even
after the holidays coming back watching
coming and being the best audience in
the entire world because we run on your
support we truly do so if you want to
support us you can go to store.d Tony
michaels.com check out all the merch
there store not beat Tony michaels.com
or you can just subscribe to the YouTube
channel where our subscriber account is
going up and up and up so subscribe to
the YouTube channel don't miss a single
thing also go over on Twitter there it
is um at Tony Michaels pod our software
changed the um the slide slides do you
notice how it has the more soft
transition now yeah yeah they change
that they change that and which I'm
happy about it makes it easier on me
also download every single episode don't
forget to download every single episode
every single weekday Monday through
Friday
on Apple Spotify Google leave us a great
review while you subscribe on your
favorite directory and Gabe you can
download bonehead of the week this
weekend in its full form you can
download it on your favorite directory
also follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels even though we're sad Jeremy
Johnson's gone you'll probably have the
other other Trump you're a Nazi it
happens then we not see you here see you
[ __ ]
in the 86 can Trash your garbage you
Nazi [ __ ] okay everyone have a great
weekend we will see you on Monday two
and a half hours Gabe we see you on
Monday same time
same place Surfside [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon